When West Jet first took flight in 1996, the vibes were a bit different. People thought denim on denim was peak fashion, inline skates were everywhere, and two out of three women rocked, the Rachel. While those things stayed in the 90s, one thing that hasn't is that fuzzy feeling you get when WestJet welcomes you on board. Here's to Westjetting since 96. Travel back in time with us and actually travel with us at westjet.com slash 30 years. We have come. We are here. Beware. Take heed. when the black cat is gliding under the shadows of darkness and the death watch ticks at the lone hour of night,
当西捷航空于1996年首次起飞时，氛围有些不同。人们认为牛仔配牛仔是巅峰时尚，轮滑鞋随处可见，每三个女性中就有两个留着“瑞秋头”。虽然这些事物留在了90年代，但有一件事没有变，那就是当你登上西捷航空时感受到的那种温馨感。为自96年以来的西捷航空干杯。与我们一起穿越回过去，并真正与我们一起在 westjet.com 斜杠 30 年旅行。我们已经来了。我们在这里。小心。注意。当黑猫在黑暗的阴影下潜行，死亡的钟声在深夜的孤寂时刻敲响时，
then we, the pale riders, are abroad. Speak in whispers and we hear you. Dream as you sleep in the inmost recesses of your house. And hovering over your beds, we gather your sleeping thoughts while our daggers are at your throat. Ravisher of liberties of the people for whom we died and yet live, Begone ere it is too late. Unholy blacks, cursed of God, take warning and fly. Twice has the sacred serpent hissed. When again his voice is heard, your doom is sealed.
那么我们，苍白的骑士，就在外面。低声细语，我们就能听到。在你的房子最深处睡觉时做梦吧。我们聚集在你的床边，收集你沉睡的思想，而我们的匕首正抵在你的喉咙上。我们为之而死却依然活着的人民的自由的掠夺者，在为时已晚之前离开吧。邪恶的黑人，被上帝诅咒的人，接受警告并逃跑吧。神圣的蛇已经嘶嘶作响两次了。当他的声音再次被听到时，你们的末日就注定了。
Beware, take heed. To be executed, be able to be executed. by a white death and rattling skeleton. At 10 tonight. K, K, K, K. So that was a chilling warning sent to the sheriff of Jackson County, Arkansas, as reported in the Little Rock Morning Republican on the 13th of May 1868. And those three letters, K, K, K, K, stand of course for the Ku Klux Klan.
小心，注意。要被处决，就要有能力被处决。被苍白的死亡和嘎嘎作响的骷髅。今晚10点。K, K, K, K。这就是发给阿肯色州杰克逊县警长的一条令人不寒而栗的警告，正如1868年5月13日的《小石城共和党晨报》所报道的那样。而那三个字母，K, K, K, K，当然代表三K党。
And I think it is worth pointing out that not only are the Ku Klux Klan, a very violent, murderous and racist, but also they can't spell. What have they misspelled? Klan. Oh, yes, with the K, the K. Yeah, it's with a C. Yes, you're not wrong, Tom. I'm not wrong. Last episode, you did that whole reading where all the Cs were turned into K's.
我认为值得指出的是，三K党不仅非常暴力、嗜杀和种族主义，而且他们还不会拼写。他们拼错了什么？Klan。哦，是的，用K，K。是的，它是用C开头的。是的，你没说错，汤姆。我没说错。上一集，你做了那整段阅读，所有的C都变成了K。
You're right to bring it up. So the lurid sort of slightly bonkers tone of that message. plunges us right into the sweltering and very polarised atmosphere of the American South in the late 1860s in the aftermath of the American Civil War. So to remind people, this is episode two of this series. We're in the era of reconstruction. Much of the South is under military administration by the United States Army, or it's been run by administrations that are allied to the radical Republican-dominated U.S. Congress.
你提出来是对的。所以那条信息那种耸人听闻、略显疯狂的基调，把我们直接带入了1860年代末美国内战结束后美国南方闷热且极度两极分化的氛围中。所以提醒大家，这是本系列的第二集。我们正处于重建时代。南方大部分地区处于美国陆军的军事管理之下，或者由与激进共和党主导的美国国会结盟的政府管理。
So last time we decided how the clan was founded in Pulaski, Tennessee, in the summer of 1866, initially a kind of social club for Confederate veterans, but it quickly evolved into something much more sinister. It spreads across the South in the next two years, heavily promoted by Democratic newspapers and becomes a vigilante group attracting white men of all classes from lawyers and doctors to kind of farmers and laborers. As figurehead is the former Confederate General Nathan Bedford Forrest, who's now an insurance salesman, among other things. And at its peak, it has dens in a quarter. I mean, we may have insurance salesmen who listen to this podcast. I don't want to be rude about insurance salesman. You know, we all need
所以上次我们决定了三K党是如何在1866年夏天在田纳西州普拉斯基成立的，最初是邦联退伍军人的某种社交俱乐部，但它很快演变成了一些更险恶的东西。它在接下来的两年里蔓延到整个南方，受到民主党报纸的大力宣传，并成为一个吸引各阶层白人男性的治安组织，从律师和医生到农民和劳工。其挂名首领是前邦联将军内森·贝德福德·福雷斯特，他现在除了其他工作外，还是一名保险推销员。在鼎盛时期，它在四分之一的地区都有窝点。我的意思是，我们可能有一些听这个播客的保险推销员。我不想对保险推销员无礼。你知道，我们都需要
insurance, Tom. Anyway, at its peak, the clan has a dends in a quarter of southern counties, has got about 150,000 members, and their targets are the three to four million newly liberated freed men and freed women of the South. And they're about a third of the population, and the other two thirds are white. So these people are the clan's targets, as well as their allies in the Republican Party. Now, we ended last time at the late summer, early autumn of 1868. So we are just weeks, really, from the first presidential election since the Civil War. And this is an election which the stakes are really, really high. This is not an ordinary political contest. This is one with existential implications, particularly if you're in the South. So on the
保险，汤姆。无论如何，在鼎盛时期，三K党在四分之一的南方县都有窝点，大约有15万名成员，他们的目标是南方三到四百万刚获得解放的黑人男女。他们大约占人口的三分之一，另外三分之二是白人。所以这些人是三K党的目标，以及他们在共和党的盟友。现在，我们上次结束于1868年的夏末秋初。所以我们离内战以来的第一次总统选举真的只有几周时间了。这是一场赌注非常非常高的选举。这不是一场普通的政治竞争。这是一场具有存在主义影响的选举，特别是如果你在南方的话。所以，在
Republican side, you have General Ulysses S. Grant. So he's from Ohio. He is a career military officer, he was seen in the north as the predominant hero, the preeminent hero of the northern war effort. Because what he had done in his sort of dogged and quiet and sort of small sea conservative way, he had harnessed the power of industry and a modern army and modern communications and all those kinds of things to wage a campaign that looked you know, like the campaign, military campaigns of the future rather than the past. He's not about swashbuckling cavalry charges. He is about grinding relentlessly forward.
共和党方面，你有尤利西斯·S·格兰特将军。他来自俄亥俄州。他是一名职业军官，在北方被视为北方战争努力的主要英雄，卓越的英雄。因为他所做的一切，以他那种顽强、安静和小写c保守的方式，他利用了工业、现代军队和现代通信的力量，以及所有这些东西，发动了一场看起来像未来而不是过去的军事战役。他不是关于那种虚张声势的骑兵冲锋。他是关于无情地向前推进。
And of course, that's what wins the war. And in the series that we did on The Assassination of Lincoln, we were inadvertently rude about him, weren't we? And implied that he may have been very corrupt. Corrupt and boring, I think, is what he called it. So he is boring, but he's not particularly corrupt, is he actually? So we should draw back on that. The trend now among historians is just to say that Grant wasn't actually that corrupt. He was a bit corrupt, but not as corrupt as some people,
当然，这就是赢得战争的原因。在我们制作的关于林肯遇刺的系列节目中，我们无意中对他无礼了，不是吗？并暗示他可能非常腐败。腐败和无聊，我想这就是他所说的。所以他很无聊，但他并不是特别腐败，对吧？所以我们应该收回这一点。现在历史学家之间的趋势只是说格兰特实际上并没有那么腐败。他有点腐败，但没有某些人那么腐败，
and that the corruption was actually systemic rather than individual. And indeed, a lot of Americans would say he wasn't actually even that boring. He was just quiet. Okay, so that's the scholarly consensus. He wasn't boring either. Shocking. We fully take that back then. This is the way history works.
而且这种腐败实际上是系统性的，而不是个人的。事实上，很多美国人会说他甚至没有那么无聊。他只是安静。好吧，这就是学术界的共识。他也不无聊。令人震惊。我们完全收回这一点。这就是历史运作的方式。
Wild swings of scholarly opinion. Okay, so he wasn't boring either. Yeah. And in our own way, we've reflected the pendulum there. Because a year ago, we said he was corrupt and boring. And now... But since then. Yeah.
学术观点的大幅摇摆。好吧，所以他也不无聊。是的。以我们自己的方式，我们反映了那里的钟摆。因为一年前，我们说他腐败且无聊。而现在……但从那以后。是的。
And I just want to make it clear to people on the Reddit. We're not responding to you. No, we're not. We're responding to trends in scholarship. That's what we always do. Yeah. Ten years of historical scholarship equals one year of the rest is history. So that's how it works.
我只是想向Reddit上的人明确一点。我们不是在回应你们。不，我们不是。我们是在回应学术界的趋势。这就是我们一直在做的。是的。十年的历史学术研究等于一年的《历史的其余部分》。这就是它的运作方式。
So Grant is very popular with business elites in New York City who want to get on with making money. He's very close to them. Hence, some of the corruption allegations later on. But Grant also supports. Congressional Reconstruction, as it is called. So this is the approach that says, let's bring law and order to the South, that let us guarantee equal rights for African Americans.
所以格兰特在纽约市的商业精英中非常受欢迎，他们想继续赚钱。他与他们非常亲近。因此，后来出现了一些腐败指控。但格兰特也支持所谓的国会重建。所以这是一种说，让我们给南方带来法律和秩序，让我们保证非裔美国人的平等权利的方法。
Come on, we didn't fight this war for nothing. We want to see proper results. On the Democrat side, they nominate the former governor of New York, Horatio Seymour. And Horatio Seymour is standing on an uncompromising platform of white supremacy. So Horatio Seymour and the Democrats say we will give amnesty to the Confederate, Come on. The war's over now. Let's all be friends. Let's restore the southern states to the Union as quickly as possible. Sure, they've been in rebellion. Let's get them back into Congress. Again, let's all be friends. And let's stop intervening in the South with the Union
得了吧，我们打这场仗不是为了什么都没有。我们想看到适当的结果。在民主党方面，他们提名了前纽约州州长霍拉肖·西摩。而霍拉肖·西摩站在一个毫不妥协的白人至上主义平台上。所以霍拉肖·西摩和民主党人说，我们将赦免邦联，得了吧。战争现在结束了。让我们都成为朋友吧。让我们尽快将南方各州恢复到联邦。当然，他们一直在叛乱。让我们把他们带回国会。再次，让我们都成为朋友吧。让我们停止用联邦军队干预南方。
army. The federal government has no business interfering in the South. That's not why we fought the war. So the tone of Seymour's campaign was set by his vice president, who was a man called Frank Blair from Missouri. I know you generally love a Blair. But Dominic, this Frank Blair, he is the worst, as people will see, when you read out what he actually said. Yeah, very shocking. He said, the radicals want to hand power to a semi-baric race of blacks who are, he said, going to subject white women to their unbridled lust. And that is such a common theme, isn't it? I mean, they're obsessed by that idea of... Completely. The fear of miscegenation, yes. Black men, deflowering white women and all of that.
联邦政府没有理由干预南方。这不是我们打这场仗的原因。所以西摩竞选活动的基调是由他的副总统设定的，他是一个来自密苏里州的叫弗兰克·布莱尔的人。我知道你通常喜欢布莱尔。但是多米尼克，这个弗兰克·布莱尔，他是最糟糕的，正如人们会看到的那样，当你读出他实际说的话时。是的，非常令人震惊。他说，激进分子想把权力交给一个半野蛮的黑人种族，他说，他们将让白人女性受到他们肆无忌惮的欲望的支配。这是一个非常普遍的主题，不是吗？我的意思是，他们痴迷于那种想法……完全是。对种族通婚的恐惧，是的。黑人男性，玷污白人女性等等。
Totally. And this is the last time, really, in a US presidential election, that white supremacy is so overtly, explicitly, the issue. One democratic tactician said explicitly, our strategy is to exploit the aversion with which the masses contemplate the equality of the Negro. So this is clearly a very highly charged campaign, and especially in the South, and this is where the Klan comes in.
完全正确。这确实是美国总统选举中最后一次白人至上主义如此公开、明确地成为议题。一位民主党策略家明确表示，我们的策略是利用大众对黑人平等的厌恶。所以这显然是一场非常激烈的竞选，特别是在南方，这就是三K党介入的地方。
Now, as we said last time, the Klan is not a top-down, cohesive organisation. You know, there isn't a headquarters from which orders go out. This is basically an alliance of loosely linked vigilante groups in the small towns and villages of the rural south. And they are united by their opposition to the Republican Party into black voting rights and by their commitment to use violence to get their way. So if we look at a couple of examples and we start with Tennessee, where the clan was founded. So in Tennessee, that election, there is extensive violence. violence in Pulaski and the surrounding countryside. Black men were threatened with death if they voted
现在，正如我们上次所说，三K党不是一个自上而下的、有凝聚力的组织。你知道，没有一个总部发出命令。这基本上是农村南方小城镇和村庄中松散联系的治安组织联盟。他们因反对共和党和黑人投票权以及致力于使用暴力来达到目的而团结在一起。所以如果我们看几个例子，我们从三K党成立的田纳西州开始。所以在田纳西州，那次选举，有广泛的暴力。普拉斯基及周边乡村的暴力。黑人男性如果投票给
Republican. They were offered protection papers. They're offered sort of indemnities if they voted Democrats. So there's not a secret ballot. People can see how you're voting. No, there's no uniform arrangements so different states can make their own different provisions. And of course, if you're voting in a small town, everybody will basically know the way you vote. They'll be clustering around you. They can watch you as you do it. Exactly. People will be watching. There'll be huge mob of people around you. Rather like, we did a series
共和党，就会受到死亡威胁。如果他们投票给民主党，就会得到保护文件。他们会得到某种赔偿。所以没有秘密投票。人们可以看到你是怎么投票的。不，没有统一的安排，所以不同的州可以制定不同的规定。当然，如果你在一个小镇投票，每个人基本上都会知道你的投票方式。他们会聚集在你周围。他们可以在你投票时看着你。完全正确。人们会看着。你周围会有大群人。就像我们做了一个关于
about elections in 18th and 19th century Britain. This is not dissimilar. There'll be huge crowds at the polls and there'll be people basically peering over your shoulders
18和19世纪英国选举的系列节目。这没什么不同。投票站会有大量人群，基本上会有人盯着你的肩膀
as you vote. So of the 2000 African Americans who have registered to vote in Pulaski, only about 600 to 700 of them turned up.
当你投票时。所以，在普拉斯基登记投票的2000名非裔美国人中，只有大约600到700人出现。
Some of them actually voted Democratic because they wanted these protection papers. They're intimidated to vote in Democratic. And as a result, the Democrats took that county by 50 votes. And it was a similar story in a lot of the other counties of Middle Tennessee.
他们中有些人实际上投票给了民主党，因为他们想要这些保护文件。他们被恐吓投票给民主党。结果，民主党以50票的优势赢得了那个县。在田纳西州中部的许多其他县，情况也类似。
So the Republican vote, historians reckon the Republican vote in this area was 10,000 votes down on what it should have been. Now, this wasn't enough to win the state for the Democrats because the Confederates, as we said last time, had been disenfranchised by the governor, Parsons Brownlow. So ex-Confederates couldn't vote. but it is a sign of how effective violence can be in elections. Take another example. Neighboring state of South Carolina.
所以共和党的选票，历史学家估计该地区的共和党选票比应该有的少了10000票。现在，这不足以让民主党赢得该州，因为正如我们上次所说，邦联分子被州长帕森斯·布朗洛剥夺了选举权。所以前邦联分子不能投票。但这标志着暴力在选举中是多么有效。再举一个例子。邻近的南卡罗来纳州。
At South Carolina, Democratic clubs handed out guns to their supporters, and they would go out riding at night, firing randomly at black people's cabins. Prominent Republican activists would find coffins marked with the three letters KKK on their doorsteps. In the worst hit county, which was Aberville County, two Republicans. Republican legislators were murdered in the days before the election. So one of them was a white man called James Martin. The other was a state senator of mixed race called B.F. Randolph, who had been a chaplain to a U.S. Army regiment, a black regiment, in the Civil War. And B.F. Randolph was shot in broad daylight on a railway platform with loads of people standing around by three men who
在南卡罗来纳州，民主党俱乐部向他们的支持者分发枪支，他们会晚上骑马出去，随机向黑人的小屋开枪。著名的共和党活动家会在家门口发现标有三个字母KKK的棺材。在受灾最严重的县，即阿伯维尔县，两名共和党人。共和党立法者在选举前几天被谋杀。其中一个是名叫詹姆斯·马丁的白人。另一个是名叫B.F.伦道夫的混血州参议员，他曾在内战中担任美国陆军一个黑人团的随军牧师。B.F.伦道夫在光天化日之下在火车站台上被三个人枪杀，周围有很多人站着，
then rode off unchallenged and were never caught and never convicted. Georgia. The Freedmen's Bureau reported 142 incidents between August and late October, 31 killings, 43 shootings, five stabbings, 55 beatings and eight whippings of 300 to 500 lashes apiece. The worst of these attacks was an attack on, again, open air, public, everybody can see. It's on a black Republican rally in the town of Camilla in South Georgia on the 19th of September. the local sheriff led the attack, 400 Klansmen, they opened fire on this parade of Republican supporters and then chased them across the countryside. They killed surprisingly few of them actually. I mean, in some ways, they killed seven people, they injured about 40 more.
然后他们骑马离开，没有受到挑战，也从未被抓获，从未被定罪。佐治亚州。自由民局报告称，8月至10月下旬期间发生了142起事件，包括31起杀戮、43起枪击、5起刺伤、55起殴打和8起每起300到500鞭的鞭刑。这些袭击中最严重的是对9月19日在佐治亚州南部卡米拉镇举行的黑人共和党集会的袭击，同样是露天、公开的，每个人都能看到。当地警长领导了这次袭击，400名三K党人向这群共和党支持者开火，然后追赶他们穿过乡村。他们实际上杀的人出奇地少。我的意思是，在某些方面，他们杀死了7个人，又打伤了大约40人。
Then on election day, you're asking Tom, you know, can you cast a secret ballot? The answer here is no. Basically armed white clansmen are at the polls. they confiscate the Republican papers, the Republican ballots from people who are trying to cast them. And as a result, to give you a lot of two counties, in Warren County, the Republican vote fell from more than 1,000 to 188. In Columbia County, it fell from 1,222 to 1 vote. And unbelievably, in 11 Georgia counties, with black majorities. So this is where the Republican vote would be really strong. Ulysses S. Grant, got no votes at all. In other words, either nobody voted for him because they were so intimidated, or basically the people who were counting the votes just said he got zero and none of those votes
然后在选举日，你问汤姆，你知道，你能投秘密选票吗？答案是不能。基本上武装的白人三K党人在投票站。他们没收了试图投票的人的共和党文件、共和党选票。结果，给你举两个县的例子，在沃伦县，共和党选票从1000多张下降到188张。在哥伦比亚县，它从1222张下降到1张。令人难以置信的是，在11个黑人占多数的佐治亚州县。所以这是共和党选票应该非常强劲的地方。尤利西斯·S·格兰特，根本没有得到选票。换句话说，要么没有人投票给他，因为他们太害怕了，要么基本上计算选票的人只是说他得了零票，而那些选票中没有一张
counted at all. And as a result, Georgia went democratic in the presidential election. And there is no attempt to kind of legislate against these results and to say, well, they're obviously corrupt or a result of intimidation. No, no, to cut a long story short. We'll get on to the legislation. So later on, there is legislation to try to deal with the Klan. They're in the Enforcement's Act and the Kukkos Klan Act. But they come a little bit later. So at the time, Grant wins the election. So because he's won the election, there's no need. And just the worst violence, actually, you haven't even got to the worst violence. The worst violence was in Louisiana. So in Louisiana, there are two different paramilitary groups doing the Democratic Party's work. There's the Kukukok's clan. And I mentioned in the last time, the Knights of of the white camellia. I can't take them seriously with that. In the, well, I mean, you definitely take them seriously if you leave in Louisiana. So they're very strong in the southern parishes of Louisiana.
被计算在内。结果，佐治亚州在总统选举中投给了民主党。而且没有试图对这些结果进行立法，说，好吧，它们显然是腐败的或恐吓的结果。不，不，长话短说。我们会谈到立法。所以后来，有立法试图处理三K党。他们有《执行法》和《三K党法》。但它们来得晚了一些。所以当时，格兰特赢得了选举。所以因为他赢得了选举，没有必要。而且实际上最严重的暴力，你甚至还没谈到最严重的暴力。最严重的暴力是在路易斯安那州。所以在路易斯安那州，有两个不同的准军事组织在为民主党工作。有三K党。我上次提到了白山茶花骑士团。我不能认真对待他们。在，好吧，我的意思是，如果你住在路易斯安那州，你肯定会认真对待他们。所以他们在路易斯安那州的南部教区非常强大。
Louisiana has parishes rather than counties. Of course, it's got its French heritage. And in the southern parishes, more than half of the white male population belongs to the knights. And they are absolutely ruthless. So in St. Landry Parish, just one parish, the knights of the white chamele killed at least 200 black people. people in the weeks and days before the election. And there is no legal government response to this at all? Here is the issue with this whole story.
路易斯安那州有教区而不是县。当然，它有法国血统。在南部教区，超过一半的白人男性人口属于骑士团。他们绝对是冷酷无情的。所以在圣兰德里教区，仅仅一个教区，白山茶花骑士团在选举前的几周和几天里至少杀害了200名黑人。而且对此根本没有任何合法的政府回应？这就是整个故事的问题所在。
I mean, the United States is a federal system, separation of powers, but also the sort of division of responsibility between the federal government and the states. Yeah, so states' rights, but states don't have the right to go around killing people. So in somewhere like Louisiana, if the state authorities are in the hands, you know, of people who want to behave in this way, right? What does the federal government do? The only thing it can do is to send in troops, right? Because it's got to enforce its will somehow.
我的意思是，美国是一个联邦制国家，权力分立，但也存在联邦政府和各州之间的责任划分。是的，所以各州的权利，但各州没有权利到处杀人。所以像路易斯安那州这样的地方，如果州当局掌握在那些想以这种方式行事的人手中，对吧？联邦政府做什么？它唯一能做的就是派遣军队，对吧？因为它必须以某种方式执行其意志。
And the problem that runs through this whole story of reconstruction is that in the north, people think, we've won the war, can we just go home now, please, and crack on with making loads of money, because actually the United States is poised to go through this tremendous transformation, you know, into this sort of industrial capitalist colossus. And they're very excited at the thought of this, making money from railroads and stuff. And they're bored. They're really bored of the arguments about the South, which have been going on for so long. But also they think they really believe in their federal system.
贯穿整个重建故事的问题是，在北方，人们认为，我们赢得了战争，我们现在能回家了吗，请继续赚钱，因为实际上美国正准备经历这种巨大的转变，你知道，变成这种工业资本主义巨头。他们对这个想法感到非常兴奋，从铁路之类的东西中赚钱。而且他们很无聊。他们真的厌倦了关于南方的争论，这些争论已经持续了太久。但他们也认为他们真的相信他们的联邦制度。
You and I might not believe in it, Tom, because we're not Americans. But they do believe in it. And they think ultimately the state should decide. Even if 200 innocent people are being killed. Well, they're shocked by this, which is why they're. they end up passing legislation. But ultimately, there is not that much, there's not that much support for federal intervention.
你和我可能不相信它，汤姆，因为我们不是美国人。但他们相信它。他们认为最终应该由各州决定。即使有200名无辜的人被杀。好吧，他们对此感到震惊，这就是为什么他们最终通过了立法。但最终，并没有那么多，并没有那么多对联邦干预的支持。
Lots of people are really unhappy about it, including, here's the thing that will amaze some people, including some people who had been really fervent abolitionists and allies of Abraham Lincoln, they basically end up saying, look, we've done our best for the freedmen of the South, we've given them emancipation, we've ended slavery, and now they just have to make the best of things.
很多人对此非常不满，包括，这里有一件事会让一些人感到惊讶，包括一些曾经是亚伯拉罕·林肯的狂热废奴主义者和盟友的人，他们基本上最终说，看，我们已经为南方的自由民尽了我们最大的努力，我们给了他们解放，我们结束了奴隶制，现在他们必须尽力而为。
Right. And, you know, it is tough for them, but they just have to make the best of it because it's more important to preserve our political system than it is basically to maintain their rights. I mean, there are lots of people who think that, and there'll be some listeners who are really ahead of me, I guess, what lies partly behind this is the fact that a lot of people in the North, even if they're anti-slavery, are still quite racist. They're deep down, they'd actually don't want to wreck their system. They would say, wreck their system or change their system for the benefit of millions of black people in the South. I think that's part of this as well. Okay. Yeah, understood. It's a hugely complicated story. I mean, I remember, I did this at university, and I can remember in our tutorial saying to our tutor, why don't they just send in the army? You know, that's what a normal country does. And, you know, him saying, well, you have to take seriously the Constitution, the principle of states of the rights of the states, you know, the principle of limited government, all of those kinds of things. If you don't take those things seriously, then you don't understand why Americans
对。而且，你知道，这对他们来说很艰难，但他们必须尽力而为，因为维护我们的政治制度比基本上维护他们的权利更重要。我的意思是，有很多人这样认为，而且会有一些听众比我领先，我想，这背后部分原因是许多北方人，即使他们是反奴隶制的，仍然相当种族主义。他们内心深处，实际上并不想破坏他们的制度。他们会说，为了南方数百万黑人的利益而破坏他们的制度或改变他们的制度。我认为这也是其中的一部分。好吧。是的，明白了。这是一个极其复杂的故事。我的意思是，我记得，我在大学里做过这个，我记得在我们的辅导课上对我们的导师说，为什么他们不直接派军队进去？你知道，那是一个正常国家会做的事情。而且，你知道，他说，好吧，你必须认真对待宪法，各州权利的原则，你知道，有限政府的原则，所有这些东西。如果你不认真对待这些事情，那么你就不会明白为什么美国人
behave as they did in the 1860s and 1870s. So anyway, to get back to the results, Grant won the election. He won 26 states to Seymour's 8, and he took the electoral college easily and he became the next president. However, there are three important takeaways from all this. Number one, everybody was shocked how close the popular vote was. So Grant won three million votes, but Seymour won 2.7 million. And so it wouldn't take that much for the Democrats to win in future, that much of a change. Secondly, historians think that Seymour probably won a majority of white votes among those white people who voted. In other words, if the Democrats can stop black people voting or drive down the black vote, they will probably win.
在1860年代和1870年代会有那样的行为。所以无论如何，回到结果，格兰特赢得了选举。他赢得了26个州，西摩赢得了8个州，他轻松拿下了选举人团，并成为了下一任总统。然而，从这一切中有三个重要的收获。第一，每个人都对普选票的接近程度感到震惊。所以格兰特赢得了300万张选票，但西摩赢得了270万张。所以民主党在未来获胜并不需要太多，不需要太大的改变。其次，历史学家认为西摩可能在投票的白人中赢得了多数白人选票。换句话说，如果民主党能阻止黑人投票或压低黑人选票，他们很可能会赢。
And thirdly, what this proves, some of these figures. In Louisiana, I mentioned, in six parishes in Louisiana, Ulysses S. Grant got one vote, and in seven parishes he got zero votes and he ended up losing Louisiana. What that proves is that paramilitary violence works. There are not enough federal troops in the South to stop it, and the number of federal troops is bound to shrink as northerners get bored and want to withdraw the troops and bring them home. So what happens after the election?
第三，这些数字证明了什么。在路易斯安那州，我提到过，在路易斯安那州的六个教区，尤利西斯·S·格兰特只得到了一张选票，在七个教区他得到了零票，他最终输掉了路易斯安那州。这证明了准军事暴力是有效的。南方没有足够的联邦军队来阻止它，而且随着北方人感到厌倦并想要撤回军队并带他们回家，联邦军队的数量必然会缩减。那么选举后发生了什么？
Grant was inaugurated on the 4th of March 1869 and he gives his inaugural address and there's lots of black supporters there actually in Washington to hear it. And Grant, you know, it's quite a... I mean, we said he's not corrupt and boring. It is actually quite a boring speech. He says he rejects prejudice and hate. He wants to see the 15th Amendment ratified
格兰特于1869年3月4日就职，他发表了就职演说，实际上华盛顿有很多黑人支持者在那里听。格兰特，你知道，这相当……我的意思是，我们说他不腐败且无聊。这实际上是一个相当无聊的演讲。他说他拒绝偏见和仇恨。他希望看到第15修正案获得批准
so the 15th Amendment would forbid any state denying you the right to vote based on your colour or your race or previous condition of servitude. In other words, basically gives ex-male slaves the right to vote. But since the election, the clan's violence has not died down. In many ways, it's actually got worse. So in Tennessee, for example, the night raids have got worse since the election. Here's one example. Parsons Brownlow, the governor, had hired a detective to infiltrate the clan in Pulaski.
所以第15修正案将禁止任何州基于你的肤色、种族或以前的奴役状况而剥夺你的投票权。换句话说，基本上赋予前男性奴隶投票权。但自选举以来，三K党的暴力并没有平息。在许多方面，它实际上变得更糟了。所以在田纳西州，例如，选举后的夜袭变得更糟了。这里有一个例子。州长帕森斯·布朗洛雇了一名侦探潜入普拉斯基的三K党。
this detective called Mr. Barmore, and he'd actually done a very good job very successfully, and he was heading home to Nashville, clearly he'd been rumbled, when a gang of masked men dragged him off and they took him into the woods and shot him. This was a big story at the time. And some white business leaders started to get anxious about this and say things getting out of hand. And what was particularly worrying them was that the Republicans in Nashville were now saying to Brownlow, are you finally going to send in this armed state militia or not, which he's been talking about for months? And on the 20th of January, Brownow finally agreed to do it. So this is nine days after his detective has been killed.
这个叫巴莫尔先生的侦探，他实际上做得非常好，非常成功，他正准备回家去纳什维尔，显然他被发现了，当时一群蒙面人把他拖走，带进树林并枪杀了。这在当时是一个大新闻。一些白人商业领袖开始对此感到焦虑，并说事情正在失控。特别让他们担心的是，纳什维尔的共和党人现在对布朗洛说，你到底是要派这支武装州民兵进去还是不派？他已经谈论了几个月了？在1月20日，布朗洛终于同意这样做了。所以这是他的侦探被杀九天后。
He says, he announces publicly, he says there's a reign of terror in Middle and West Tennessee. I want to call up recruits to the militia. I will declare martial law. Let's occupy their towns, all of this kinds of thing. And at this point, the Tennessee clan clearly panics. So the Imperial Wizard, Nathan Bedford Forrest, issued an order. he said, I want everyone to go in and basically decommission their masks and disguises. So go to see your grand cyclops with your mask and disguise.
他公开宣布，他说田纳西州中部和西部存在恐怖统治。我想召集民兵新兵。我将宣布戒严。让我们占领他们的城镇，所有这些事情。在这一点上，田纳西州三K党显然惊慌失措。所以帝国巫师，内森·贝德福德·福雷斯特，发布了一项命令。他说，我希望每个人都进去，基本上销毁他们的面具和伪装。所以去见你的大独眼巨人，带着你的面具和伪装。
You must destroy them in front of him. He says, no more whippings, no more lynchings, no more beatings, none of this, no provocations. And incredibly, in the next few weeks, the Tennessee clan, the original one, actually disbands. So we don't know exactly when, but sometime in late spring or summer of 1869, the white Tennessee the clan leadership basically renounces the clan, and that's the end of it. So it's a massive result for Parsons Brownlow. Well, it looks like it, but actually there's a twist. Oh, no.
你必须在他面前销毁它们。他说，不再有鞭刑，不再有私刑，不再有殴打，没有这些，没有挑衅。令人难以置信的是，在接下来的几周里，田纳西州三K党，最初的那个，实际上解散了。所以我们不知道确切的时间，但在1869年的晚春或夏天，白人田纳西州三K党领导层基本上放弃了三K党，这就是它的终结。所以这对帕森斯·布朗洛来说是一个巨大的结果。好吧，看起来是这样，但实际上有一个转折。哦，不。
The reason they've done it is partly because they don't actually need it anymore. Because Parsons Brownlow has just gone off to Washington to become a United States senator from Tennessee. And his replacement is a man inevitably called DeWitt Clinton Center. A Clinton. And DeWitt Clinton Center is much less radical than Pastor Brownlow. He says, I'll give Confederates the vote again. I'll disband the militia. And DeWitt Clinton Center does something that is very ominous.
他们这样做的原因部分是因为他们实际上不再需要它了。因为帕森斯·布朗洛刚刚去华盛顿成为田纳西州的美国参议员。他的继任者是一个不可避免地叫德威特·克林顿·森特的人。一个克林顿。而德威特·克林顿·森特比帕森斯·布朗洛激进得多。他说，我会再次给邦联分子投票权。我会解散民兵。而德威特·克林顿·森特做了一件非常不祥的事情。
He says, obviously I respect the right to vote for everybody, including African Americans, as long as you can afford to pay a poll tax. So essentially, in Best Clinton manner, he's triangulating. He is triangulated, but he's triangulating in a way that is very disadvantageous to black. voting. And basically, this is the story of the South in the next few years. This is what they're going to do. This is how the South is going to be, in inverted commas, redeemed for the Democratic Party and the cause of white supremacy. They will bring in all kinds of wheezes to stop black people voting, like poll taxes or literacy tests and so on. And so that September,
他说，显然我尊重每个人的投票权，包括非裔美国人，只要你能负担得起人头税。所以本质上，以最好的克林顿方式，他正在进行三角定位。他进行了三角定位，但他进行的三角定位对黑人投票非常不利。基本上，这就是未来几年南方的故事。这就是他们要做的。这就是南方将如何，用引号括起来，为民主党和白人至上主义事业而“救赎”。他们将引入各种各样的诡计来阻止黑人投票，比如人头税或识字测试等等。所以那年9月，
a local newspaper in Tennessee prints what it claims is a last message from the clan, which is attributed to the grand tycoon. I don't think we had a grand tycoon in the previous episode. I don't think we did. This is a Guilted Age development, is it? Yeah, exactly. Exactly. Robert Barron, man in a massive top hat. And the Grand Tycoon says,
田纳西州的一家当地报纸刊登了它声称是来自三K党的最后一条信息，归功于大亨。我不认为我们在上一集中有大亨。我不认为我们有。这是镀金时代的发展，是吗？是的，完全正确。完全正确。罗伯特·巴伦，戴着巨大高帽的人。而大亨说，
our mission on earth, to some extent, is ended. For the present, and we hope forever, we are done. So that's them done in Tennessee. But outside Tennessee, the clan rides on. Because outside Tennessee, nobody cares what, you know, the Imperial Wizard General Forest wants. They're fighting their own battles. And the reason they're doing that and why these battles
我们在地球上的使命，在某种程度上，已经结束了。目前，我们希望永远，我们完成了。所以这就是他们在田纳西州的终结。但在田纳西州之外，三K党继续骑行。因为在田纳西州之外，没有人关心，你知道，帝国巫师福雷斯特将军想要什么。他们正在打他们自己的仗。他们这样做的原因以及为什么这些战斗
are more vicious than ever, is that in some southern states, it's really only in 1869 or 1870 that the occupying U.S. Army hands over power to elected radical Republican legislators. So it's actually only at this point that in some of these states like South Carolina or Louisiana or Mississippi, you see what enfranchising the former slaves really means. So if you take the example of those three states, South Carolina, Louisiana, Mississippi, They had had very large slave populations before the war. And that means that basically when black people are given the vote, you are going to get hundreds of elected black officials,
比以往任何时候都更恶毒，是因为在一些南方州，实际上只有在1869年或1870年，占领的美国陆军才将权力移交给当选的激进共和党立法者。所以实际上只有在这一点上，在南卡罗来纳州、路易斯安那州或密西西比州等一些州，你才能看到赋予前奴隶选举权真正意味着什么。所以如果你以那三个州为例，南卡罗来纳州、路易斯安那州、密西西比州，它们在战前有非常庞大的奴隶人口。这意味着基本上当黑人获得投票权时，你将会有数百名当选的黑人官员，
many of whom had been slaves right up to 1863, the Emancipation Proclamation. They had lived in plantation counties. They had literally belonged to the richest, most powerful, most conservative white men in the land, and now they're making the laws. So South Carolina sends eight black men to Congress. Its state legislature in South Carolina had a black majority.
其中许多人直到1863年《解放宣言》之前一直是奴隶。他们住在种植园县。他们实际上属于这片土地上最富有、最强大、最保守的白人，现在他们正在制定法律。所以南卡罗来纳州向国会派遣了八名黑人。南卡罗来纳州的州议会有一个黑人多数。
Louisiana has a black governor, the first in American history, a man with the excellent name of PBS Pinchback. And Mississippi has the first black United States senator, a man called Hiram Rhodes Revels. And these people, if you've ever, well, we'll be talking about the film, The Birth of a Nation next week. If you watch that film, or if you read that film, or if you read, a book of about American history, published up to about 1940, these people are portrayed as incompetent, stupid, corrupt, childish, totally ill-suited for political life. And actually,
路易斯安那州有一位黑人州长，美国历史上第一位，一个名字非常出色的叫P.B.S.平奇巴克的人。而密西西比州有第一位黑人美国参议员，一个叫海勒姆·罗兹·雷维尔斯的人。这些人，如果你曾经，好吧，我们下周会谈论电影《一个国家的诞生》。如果你看那部电影，或者如果你读那部电影，或者如果你读一本关于美国历史的书，出版于1940年左右，这些人被描绘成无能、愚蠢、腐败、幼稚，完全不适合政治生活。实际上，
historians now would say these descriptions are unbelievably racist. And actually, these guys were doing the best possible job they could in horrific circumstances and were completely introduced by generations of historians. And what those historians were reflecting is the fact that for white Southerners to have PBS pinchback governing your state or Hiram Rhodes revels representing your state in the US Senate, it's an unbelievable affront. If you've been raised before the war in the worldview of white supremacy, and you don't even think that a black man is a human being, and you basically, I mean,
历史学家现在会说这些描述是令人难以置信的种族主义。实际上，这些家伙在可怕的情况下尽了他们所能做的最好的工作，并且被几代历史学家完全误导了。而那些历史学家所反映的是，对于南方白人来说，让P.B.S.平奇巴克治理你的州或海勒姆·罗兹·雷维尔斯在参议院代表你的州，这是一个令人难以置信的侮辱。如果你在战前是在白人至上主义的世界观中长大的，你甚至不认为黑人是一个人，你基本上，我的意思是，
to give you an example, this jumped out of me, this detail from one of the books, I think it was Alan's release. The white southerners have been raised in a world where if you walked down the street and a black man bowed to you and said good morning to you, you would whip him. Even though he'd shown you this courtesy, you would whip him because he had dared to speak to you before you spoke to him. I mean, unbelievable. And now they've got a black governor. And now they've got a black governor. This is why. I mean, this, that world for you. That world for you. were so entrenched. I mean, that is the thing that is perhaps hardest
给你举个例子，这从我身上跳了出来，来自其中一本书的这个细节，我想是艾伦·里利斯的。南方白人在一个世界中长大，如果你走在街上，一个黑人向你鞠躬并对你说早上好，你会鞭打他。即使他向你表示了这种礼貌，你也会鞭打他，因为他竟敢在你对他说话之前对你说话。我的意思是，令人难以置信。现在他们有了一个黑人州长。现在他们有了一个黑人州长。这就是为什么。我的意思是，这个，那个世界对你来说。那个世界对你来说。如此根深蒂固。我的意思是，这也许是最难的
for people in the 21st century outside that part of the world to get their heads around. Just how deeply entrenched and how deeply embedded that worldview is. And that's what lies behind this surge of violence
对于21世纪那个地区以外的人来说，理解这一点。那种世界观是多么根深蒂固，多么深入人心。这就是在接下来的几年里，密西西比州、阿拉巴马州、佐治亚州、卡罗来纳州等地暴力激增背后的原因。当我们谈论死亡人数时，无限期地在数百人，也许500、600、600、700人是可能的。
across places like Mississippi, Alabama, Georgia, the Carolinas in the next couple of years. And when we're talking about a death toll, indefinitely in the hundreds, maybe 500, 600, 600, 700 people are possible to say.
这种死亡人数可能与1970年代初北爱尔兰的动乱相当。这是给我们英国听众的一个参考。在北爱尔兰的动乱中，人们经常说这种暴力，好吧，这只是无意识的暴徒行为，这（你知道，这很容易对三K党说），但这绝对不是无意识的暴徒行为。它是非常、非常经过计算的。重建的杰出历史学家，最伟大的之一，
The sort of death toll that might be comparable to the troubles in Northern Ireland in the first part of the 1970s. That's a reference for our British listeners. And in the troubles in Northern Ireland, people would often say of this violence, well, it's just mindless thuggery, which, you know, it's easy to say about the Ku Klux Klan, but it's absolutely not mindless thuggery at all. It's very, very calculated. The brilliant historian of Reconstruction, one of the greatest,
美国历史学家埃里克·方纳在他的关于重建的大书中写到了这一点。他说，引用，实际上，三K党是一支服务于民主党、种植园主阶级以及所有渴望恢复白人至上主义的人的利益的军事力量。其目的是在最广泛的意义上是政治性的，即摧毁共和党的基建，破坏重建州，重新建立对黑人劳动力的控制，并在南方生活的各个方面恢复种族从属地位。所以，多米尼克，为了追求北爱尔兰的比较，三K党对民主党来说，就像爱尔兰共和军对新芬党一样？是的，我认为这不是一个不合理的比较。我认为你可以说他们是
American historians Eric Foner writes about this in his big book on Reconstruction. He says, quote, in effect, the clan was a military force serving the interests of the Democratic Party, the planter class, and all those who desired the restoration of white supremacy. Its purposes were political in the broadest sense to destroy the Republican Party's infrastructure, undermine the reconstruction state, reestablish control of the black labor force, and restore racial subordination in every aspect of southern life. So, Dominic, to pursue the the Northern Ireland comparison, the Ku Klux Klan are to the Democrats, what the IRA are to Sinn Féin? Yeah, I think that's not an unreasonable comparison. I think you could say they are the
政治运动的武装派别。是的。因为他们一直受到民主党报纸的支持。他们与民主党政客联系非常紧密。你知道，他们的目标是摧毁共和党。所以是的，绝对。我的意思是，一位佛罗里达州的政客。那个叫伊曼纽尔·福琼的人，他被三K党赶出了佛罗里达州的杰克逊县。他说，它的目的是杀死共和党的领导人，那些立场鲜明的人。所以有很多可怕的故事，那种酷刑、谋杀等等。这里只是一个例子，显然这是一个相当严峻的故事，所以请做好准备。
kind of armed wing of a political movement. Yeah. Because they've been supported by Democratic newspapers. They're very closely linked to Democratic politicians. You know, their aim is to destroy the Republican Party. So yeah, absolutely. I mean, it's quite one Florida politician. The guy could Emmanuel Fortune, who was driven out of Jackson County, Florida by the clan. He said the object of it is to kill the leading men of the Republican Party, men who've taken a prominent stand. So there are many terrible stories, kind of torture, murder and whatnot. Here's just one example, and obviously it is a pretty grim story, so prepare yourselves.
有一个叫亚伯拉罕·科尔比的人，他是爱尔兰种植园主和他的奴隶的儿子。所以他生来就是奴隶，是主人的儿子，后来他的父亲释放了他。他成为了一名教会牧师。他是一位出色的演说家。1866年，在战争结束后，他组织了一个平等权利协会的分支。他住在佐治亚州的格林县，在1868年，他当选为格林县的佐治亚州众议院议员。一年后的1869年10月，他被一群60名三K党人从床上拖走，他们把他带到了树林里，还有和他一起在小屋里的他的母亲、妻子和女儿。他们在他的家人面前剥光了他的衣服，然后他们鞭打了他三次
There's a guy called Abram Colby, and he was the son of an Irish plantation owner and his slave. So he was born into slavery, the son of the owner, and then his father later freed him. He became a church minister. He was a brilliant speaker. In 1866, in the aftermath of the war, he organised a branch of the Equal Rights Association. He lived in Green County, Georgia, and in In 1868, he was elected to the Georgia House of Representatives from Green County. A year later in 1869, in October, he was dragged from his bed by a mob of 60 clansmen, and they took him out into the woods, along with his mother, his wife and his daughter who were in the cabin with him. And they stripped him naked in front of his family, and then they whipped him for three
有一个人叫亚伯拉罕·科尔比，他是爱尔兰种植园主与他奴隶的儿子。因此他生来就是奴隶，是主人的儿子，后来他的父亲给了他自由。他成为了一名牧师，也是一位出色的演说家。1866年，在战争结束后，他组织了一个平等权利协会的分支机构。他住在佐治亚州的格林县，1868年，他当选为格林县的佐治亚州众议院议员。一年后的1869年10月，他被一群60人的三K党暴徒从床上拖走，他们把他和当时在小屋里的母亲、妻子和女儿一起带到了树林里。他们在他的家人面前剥光了他的衣服，然后鞭打了他的三
hours. And we know this because he testified to a congressional committee about it three years later. and he said of the men who had attacked him, they weren't disguised. They didn't need to disguise themselves because they knew they could do this with impunity. He said of them, some of them are first-class men in our town. One is a lawyer, one a doctor, and some are farmers. They had their pistols. They took me in my nightclothes and carried me from home. They hit me 5,000 blows. They said I had voted for Grant and had carried the Negroes against them. And while they're doing this, they're holding a gun to his little daughter's head. And I quote, they actually frightened her to death. She never got over it until she died, i.e. she died of shock. That was the part that grieves me the most. Then the
小时。我们之所以知道这一点，是因为他三年后在国会委员会作证时提到了这件事。他谈到袭击他的那些人时说，他们没有伪装。他们不需要伪装，因为他们知道自己可以逍遥法外。他谈到他们时说，他们当中有些人是我们镇上的头等人物。一个是律师，一个是医生，还有一些是农民。他们带着手枪。他们把我从睡梦中抓走，从家里带出来。他们打了我不下5000下。他们说我投票给了格兰特，还带着黑人反对他们。当他们这样做的时候，他们正用枪指着他小女儿的头。我引用他的话，他们真的把她吓死了。她直到去世都没能缓过来，也就是说，她是因惊吓而死。那是最让我悲痛的部分。然后
committee said to him, how long before you recovered from the effects of this treatment? Answer, I have never got over it yet. They broke something inside of me. I cannot do any work now, although I always made my living before. You know, a really sad story. There's no happy ending to this. There are larger scale attacks, so there were attacks on Republican rallies, for example, a place called Utah, Alabama, in 1874 people were killed. In the same month, in Lawrence County, South Carolina, the clan drove 150 people out of their homes. They murdered 13 people, including a white judge and a black legislator. And then an incredible story, six months later, Meridian, Mississippi.
委员会问他，你花了多久才从这种折磨的影响中恢复过来？回答是，我至今还没恢复过来。他们打碎了我身体里的某些东西。我现在什么活都干不了，尽管我以前一直靠自己谋生。你知道，这是一个非常悲伤的故事。这并没有一个圆满的结局。还有更大规模的袭击，例如，1874年在一个叫犹他（Utah）的阿拉巴马州小镇，共和党集会遭到了袭击，有人被杀。同月，在南卡罗来纳州的劳伦斯县，三K党将150人赶出了家园。他们谋杀了13人，包括一名白人法官和一名黑人议员。然后是一个令人难以置信的故事，六个月后，密西西比州的梅里迪安。
Three black leaders were arrested by the white authorities who were based in league with the clan for making what they said were incendiary speeches. And at their court hearing, the court hearing was invaded by Klansman. The Klansman killed the judge at the court hearing, a Republican, and two of the defendants, and then ran a mock in the town and killed about 30 people, including, and I quote, all of the leading colored men of the town. So, you know, you were asking before, how is it they're able to do this and get away with it? I mean, basically, because if you stand against them, they will kill you. And there are not enough federal troops to make a difference.
三名黑人领袖被与三K党勾结的白人当局逮捕，罪名是发表了他们所谓的煽动性演讲。在他们的听证会上，三K党成员闯入了法庭。三K党成员在听证会上杀死了那名共和党法官和两名被告，然后在镇上横行霸道，杀害了大约30人，其中包括——我引用一下——镇上所有有影响力的有色人种。所以，你知道，你之前问过，他们怎么能做到这一点并逃脱惩罚？我的意思是，基本上是因为如果你反抗他们，他们就会杀了你。而且联邦军队的数量不足以改变局面。
And there's not enough will in Washington or in the north to intervene on such a scale. You would have to be a massive scale, right? You'd have to flood every southern county with troops in order to stop this. And I suppose that every act of violence is a testing of the boundaries, a kind of stress testing of how able the federal government is to respond to outrages like this. And so presumably the more they realize you can get away with, the more the violence escalates. Right. Well, you just keep doing it because it works.
华盛顿或北方也没有足够的意愿进行如此大规模的干预。那必须是极其大规模的行动，对吧？你必须用军队淹没每一个南方县城才能阻止这一切。我想，每一次暴力行为都是对底线的试探，是对联邦政府应对此类暴行能力的一种压力测试。所以大概他们越意识到自己可以逍遥法外，暴力行为就越升级。没错。好吧，你只是继续这样做，因为这很有效。
I mean, it works. So here's the other thing that you were asking about before. So Eric Foner used the phrase, in that bit I quoted from Eric Foner, he said it was political and the broadest sense. And you asked about people who can read and write and so on. The clan is determined to crush churches and schools. They kill white teachers, black teachers. They will beat people who rent rooms to teachers. There's an example of an Irish teacher called William Lynch.
我的意思是，这很有效。所以这是你之前问过的另一件事。埃里克·方纳（Eric Foner）用了这个短语，在我引用的那段埃里克·方纳的话中，他说这是广义上的政治行为。你问到了那些能读会写的人等等。三K党决心摧毁教堂和学校。他们杀害白人教师、黑人教师。他们会殴打那些把房间租给老师的人。有一个叫威廉·林奇（William Lynch）的爱尔兰老师的例子。
He was working in a black school in Cross Plains, Alabama. He was dragged from his house and lynched. They will target people who can, as I said, who can read and write, who have their own land, who have their own livestock, people who don't doff their hats to white passes by, people who don't give up the sidewalk, the pavement. people who speak disrespectfully, they will even attack, quote, women who dress up and fix up like they thought anything of themselves.
他在阿拉巴马州克罗斯普莱恩斯（Cross Plains）的一所黑人学校工作。他被从家里拖出来并被私刑处死。正如我所说，他们会针对那些能读会写、拥有自己的土地、拥有自己的牲畜的人，针对那些不向路过的白人脱帽致敬的人，针对那些不让出人行道的人。针对那些说话不恭敬的人，他们甚至会攻击那些“打扮得好像自己了不起”的女性。
So in other words, black women who have a little bit about them. So basically it's about keeping them in helitage. Yes, completely it is. So it's an awful picture, terrible picture, and yet we haven't actually got to the worst of it. Because there is one county where the clan wields unparalleled power, where its word is law and you cannot challenge it. To quote Alan Trillis, the brilliant historian of the first clan,
换句话说，就是那些有点个性的黑人女性。所以基本上这就是为了让她们保持卑微。是的，完全是这样。所以这是一个可怕的画面，极其糟糕的画面，然而我们还没有讲到最糟糕的部分。因为有一个县，三K党在那里拥有无与伦比的权力，那里的话就是法律，你无法挑战它。引用第一代三K党杰出的历史学家艾伦·特雷利斯（Alan Trellise）的话，
In this county, in every subject, the clan was supreme, a juggernaut propelled forward by the size and character of its membership and the terror it inspired in every person in the county, including its own members. And this place was York County, South Carolina. And we will find out what happened there and how the Grant administration was finally roused to fight back against and destroy the clan after the break. This episode is brought to you by the Folio Society. And it's Tabby and Dominic here from the book club, Gollhanger's latest show. Now Tabby, as you know, there are some books that you read once, but there are others you especially return to again and again. And those second kind of books, they really deserve to last, don't they?
在这个县，在任何议题上，三K党都是至高无上的，它是一辆由其成员的规模和性质以及它在县内每个人（包括其自身成员）心中激发的恐惧所推动的庞然大物。这个地方就是南卡罗来纳州的约克县（York County）。休息过后，我们将了解那里发生了什么，以及格兰特政府是如何最终被唤醒并反击并摧毁三K党的。本集由Folio Society赞助播出。我是来自读书俱乐部的塔比（Tabby）和多米尼克（Dominic），这是Gollhanger最新的节目。现在塔比，如你所知，有些书你读过一次就够了，但有些书你特别会反复阅读。而第二种书，它们确实值得流传，不是吗？
That's what the Folio Society does. They are an independent, employee-owned publisher based in London. Every book is produced with specially commissioned beautiful artwork and a specially commissioned introduction that puts the story in its context. Folio Society publishes the books we love, from Bronte to Dickens, from Margaret Atwood to Tom Holland. The books can feel like works of art in their own right. They're built around the text, the stories that last in books that are made to last.
这就是Folio Society所做的。他们是一家总部位于伦敦的独立、员工持股的出版商。每一本书都配有特别委托制作的精美插图和特别委托撰写的导言，将故事置于其背景中。Folio Society出版我们喜爱的书籍，从勃朗特到狄更斯，从玛格丽特·阿特伍德到汤姆·霍兰德。这些书本身就像艺术品一样。它们围绕着文本构建，是那些经久不衰的故事和旨在长久保存的书籍。
If a story matters, keep it properly. Find it at foliosociety.com slash the book club. That's foliosociety.com slash the book club. Hello everyone and welcome back to the rest is history. We are now in the state of South Carolina and South Carolina of course had played a key role in the Civil War. It had been the first sudden state to secede from the Union back in December 1860 and it had been the state
如果一个故事很重要，就好好保存它。请访问 foliosociety.com/thebookclub。网址是 foliosociety.com/thebookclub。大家好，欢迎回到《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。我们现在在南卡罗来纳州，南卡罗来纳州当然在内战中发挥了关键作用。它是1860年12月第一个脱离联邦的南方州，也是
where the first shots of the Civil War had been fired in April 1861. So Dominic, what is the context in South Carolina? What is the kind of the racial balance, all of that kind of thing? Its population is about 60% black and 40% white. Now, given those racial demographics, it will not surprise people to know that in 1868, it had voted Republican. It had voted for Ulysses S. Grant.
1861年4月打响内战第一枪的州。那么多米尼克，南卡罗来纳州的背景是什么？种族平衡之类的状况如何？它的人口中大约60%是黑人，40%是白人。现在，考虑到这种种族人口结构，人们不会感到惊讶的是，在1868年，它投票支持了共和党。它投票支持了尤利西斯·S·格兰特（Ulysses S. Grant）。
And in 1870, it elected as governor, a former United States, a northern army officer called Robert Kingston Scott, and it voted him in by a margin of 60 to 40. So basically the voting completely follows the racial demographics. Now, the state legislature I mentioned in the first half has a black majority,
1870年，它选举了一位前美国北方军队军官罗伯特·金斯顿·斯科特（Robert Kingston Scott）担任州长，投票优势为60比40。所以基本上投票结果完全符合种族人口结构。现在，我在前半部分提到的州议会拥有黑人多数席位，
again, reflecting the demographic makeup of the state. So in any fair election, it is pretty obvious that South Carolina will always go with the Republicans, you know, unless there's some, you know, they've been incredibly corrupt or something. Yeah, the white Southerners in South Carolina are never going to get their way. And they were furious and horrified at the result of the 1870 gubernatorial election. So Alan Trellise in his history of the clan quotes the Charleston Daily News. Now, unbelievably, this was a moderate democratic newspaper.
再次反映了该州的人口构成。所以，在任何公平的选举中，很明显南卡罗来纳州总是会支持共和党，除非他们极其腐败之类的。是的，南卡罗来纳州的南方白人永远无法如愿以偿。他们对1870年州长选举的结果感到愤怒和震惊。所以艾伦·特雷利斯在他的三K党历史中引用了《查尔斯顿日报》（Charleston Daily News）。难以置信的是，这还是一份温和的民主党报纸。
So this is what a moderate democratic newspaper sounds. like. We regard the solid black vote cast against the nominees of our party as a declaration of war by the Negro race against the white race, by ignorance against intelligence, by poverty against wealth. And the Charleston Daily News went on to say, it is now the duty of white men to organise an arm in the name of decency, purity and political freedom. To repeat, this is a moderate newspaper, not an extreme one. And so this sets the tone for two years, of horrendous violence in upstate South Carolina and what's called the Piedmont region.
所以这就是一份温和的民主党报纸的声音。我们认为黑人投票反对我们党提名的候选人，是黑人种族对白人种族的宣战，是无知对智慧的宣战，是贫穷对财富的宣战。《查尔斯顿日报》接着说，现在白人有责任以体面、纯洁和政治自由的名义组织起来并武装自己。再说一遍，这是一份温和的报纸，而不是极端的报纸。这为南卡罗来纳州北部地区（即所谓的皮埃蒙特地区）两年的恐怖暴力奠定了基调。
This is a region where black and white are pretty evenly divided. So it's kind of all to play for. And the very worst county is York County. And in York County, almost every single white man joined the Ku Klux Klan. So this is right at the top of,
这是一个黑人和白人比例相当的地区。所以这基本上是势均力敌。最糟糕的县是约克县。在约克县，几乎每一个白人都加入了三K党。所以这就在
if you look at a map, it's at the top of South Carolina. It's just south of the city of Charlotte in North Carolina today. It was a rural county, about 25,000 people, cotton, serials, that kind of thing. The clan had been founded there in 1868. It had been actually reasonably quiet until the 1870 election for governor, which the Republicans had narrowly won in the county by about 500 votes.
如果你看地图，它位于南卡罗来纳州的顶部。它就在今天北卡罗来纳州夏洛特市的南边。这是一个农村县，大约有25,000人，种植棉花、谷物之类的作物。三K党于1868年在那里成立。直到1870年的州长选举，共和党在该县以大约500票的微弱优势获胜之前，那里一直相当平静。
And that was the spark that basically set off, you know, this kind of racist bonfire. I'm not sure where this metaphor is going. But anyway, in the next few weeks after that election, and the clan spread exponentially. The local leader was the sheriff, Major James W. Avery. He was a Confederate war veteran. He was actually wounded at Appomattox on the last day of the one, the last morning of the war.
那基本上就是点燃这场种族主义大火的火花。我不确定这个比喻要表达什么。但无论如何，在选举后的几周内，三K党呈指数级扩张。当地的领导人是警长，詹姆斯·W·艾弗里少校（Major James W. Avery）。他是一名南方邦联战争老兵。他实际上是在战争的最后一天，也就是战争的最后一个早晨在阿波马托克斯（Appomattox）受伤的。
And he was a planter, a bigwig in the local area. He owned the big store in Yorkville, which was the kind of county seat. And he's one of many bigwigs involved with the clan. So another one is one of the county's richest landowners, a man called William C. Black. And it was William C. Black who ordered the first notable murder. And this was the murder of a man called Tom Roundtree. Tom Roundtree was a spokesman for the African American, the freedmen of the county. And he was a married man with children. And in December 1870, a mob of Klansman came to his house, they dragged him out, they shot him, and they cut his throat. His widow was able to identify some of the killers. But this landowner, William C. Black, paid. for the defence of the killers. He organised it. He sorted out alibis for them. And in the end, Mrs. Roundtree and her children were driven from their home and had to flee the county. And that set
他是一个种植园主，是当地的大人物。他拥有约克维尔（Yorkville）的大商店，那是该县的县治。他是参与三K党的众多大人物之一。另一个是该县最富有的土地所有者之一，一个叫威廉·C·布莱克（William C. Black）的人。正是威廉·C·布莱克下令进行了第一次著名的谋杀。这就是汤姆·朗特里（Tom Roundtree）的谋杀案。汤姆·朗特里是该县非裔美国人、获得自由的奴隶的代言人。他是一个有妻子和孩子的已婚男人。1870年12月，一群三K党暴徒来到他家，把他拖出来，开枪打死，并割断了他的喉咙。他的遗孀能够认出一些凶手。但这个土地所有者威廉·C·布莱克为凶手的辩护支付了费用。他组织了这一切。他为他们安排了不在场证明。最终，朗特里夫人和她的孩子们被赶出了家园，不得不逃离该县。这奠定了
the tone for weeks of violence. 11 people murdered. Hundreds of people beaten and whipped, including women and children. Five black schools were burned down. One of them was burned down four times. They kept rebuilding it and they just burned it down again. And to give, again, to give people a bit of context. This is in a county, all of these killings and burnings and whatnot, is in a county with a population roughly the size of the town of Stratford-upon-Avon today. So imagine, you know, the furority, right, if so many people were to be killed in Stratford-upon-Avon, but obviously this is in the context of the 1870s when violence is much more common. Well, we talked about stress testing how far you can go, kind of testing the boundaries of
数周暴力事件的基调。11人被谋杀。数百人被殴打和鞭打，包括妇女和儿童。五所黑人学校被烧毁。其中一所被烧毁了四次。他们不断重建，而他们就不断地再次烧毁它。为了给人们一点背景信息，所有这些杀戮和焚烧事件发生在一个人口规模大致相当于今天埃文河畔斯特拉特福（Stratford-upon-Avon）小镇的县里。所以想象一下，如果这么多人被杀，埃文河畔斯特拉特福会是多么愤怒，但显然这是在1870年代暴力事件更为普遍的背景下。好吧，我们谈到了压力测试，测试你可以走多远，测试
permissible behavior. And this must surely be pushing at those boundaries to the extreme. I mean, can the federal government ignore violence on this scale? Well, what they do is the federal government did send in some troops. They sent in a detachment of troops in late February. But that only, the federal troops generally, when they're sent in, they don't do anything. They don't really have orders what to do. Who are they going to fight? They're always told, cooperate, please, with the local authorities. So they're like UN peacekeepers? They're totally like UN peacekeepers. They're like UN peacekeepers at Srebrenica or something, standing idly by looking a little bit bewildered because the people they're meant to be working with, they're actually the people
可容忍行为的界限。这肯定是在将这些界限推向极端。我的意思是，联邦政府能忽视这种规模的暴力吗？好吧，他们所做的是，联邦政府确实派了一些军队。他们在2月底派了一支部队。但那只是，联邦军队通常在被派去时，什么也不做。他们真的没有接到该做什么的命令。他们要和谁打仗？他们总是被告知，请与当地当局合作。所以他们就像联合国维和人员？他们完全就像联合国维和人员。他们就像斯雷布雷尼察（Srebrenica）的联合国维和人员一样，袖手旁观，看起来有点困惑，因为他们本应与之合作的人，实际上正是那些
who are carrying out the crimes. So the Klansmen actually, after the federal troops came in, they carried on killing people. And then on the 6th of March, they carried out one of the most notorious of all Klan murders. This was the murderer of man called Jim Williams. Jim Williams was about 40 years old. He'd been a slave in York County before the war, but he'd escaped. He'd run away. He'd joined the Northern Army.
正在实施犯罪的人。所以三K党成员实际上在联邦军队进入后，继续杀人。然后在3月6日，他们实施了所有三K党谋杀案中最臭名昭著的一起。这就是吉姆·威廉姆斯（Jim Williams）的谋杀案。吉姆·威廉姆斯大约40岁。战前他曾是约克县的奴隶，但他逃跑了。他逃走了。他加入了北方军队。
and then he came back to his old county after the war. He spoke out against the clan and he organized a militia. This goes back to your point about why don't black people arm themselves? Well, he did and this is what happened. He used the local Union League, the sort of political organization for the freedmen, to arm themselves, you know, let's protect ourselves, all of this kind of thing. We're not going to take us lying down. And the clan invited him to a kind of parley at a crossroads on the 11th of February.
战后他回到了原来的县。他公开反对三K党并组织了一支民兵。这回到了你关于为什么黑人不武装自己的观点？好吧，他确实武装了，这就是发生的事情。他利用当地的“工会联盟”（Union League），即那种为获得自由的奴隶提供的政治组织，来武装自己，你知道，让我们保护自己，诸如此类的事情。我们不会坐以待毙。三K党在2月11日邀请他在一个十字路口进行某种谈判。
met on the 11th of February and he said, look, we will stand down and we'll actually give up our weapons if you promised to stop raiding. And the clan said, sure, we'll stop raiding. The next day the truce broke down when the clan killed another eight people. And Williams said, well, there's no way we're going to give up our weapons now. The clan spread rumors around the couch. They said, Williams is keeping his weapons because he's planning to lead an uprising of black people to murder and rape, you know, all the white people in the county. And on the night of the 6th of March, a local doctor called J. Rufus Bratton, who was the nephew, I think not coincidentally, of the man who had once owned Williams, the slave owner who'd once
2月11日会面时他说，看，如果我们停止袭击，我们会撤退并交出武器。三K党说，当然，我们会停止袭击。第二天，当三K党又杀了八个人时，休战协议破裂了。威廉姆斯说，好吧，现在我们绝不可能交出武器。三K党在县里散布谣言。他们说，威廉姆斯保留武器是因为他计划领导一场黑人起义，去谋杀和强奸县里所有的白人。3月6日晚上，一位名叫J·鲁弗斯·布拉顿（J. Rufus Bratton）的当地医生，他我想并非巧合地是曾经拥有威廉姆斯的那个奴隶主的侄子，那个曾经
treated him as property. This doctor, Dr. Bratton, assembled a gang of 60 men wearing masks. They broke into Williams' cabin and they found him hiding under the floorboards. They dragged him out and they hanged him. from a tree. Terrible story of this, and they left him hanging there for days with the placard that read Captain Jim Williams on his big muster. Doctors are not coming well out of this story. No, doctors, lawyers, they're terrible people. They come out really badly from this story. Now, actually, at this point, some respectable white citizens in York County started to worry
把他当作财产对待的人。这位布拉顿医生召集了一伙60名戴着面具的人。他们闯入威廉姆斯的木屋，发现他躲在地板下。他们把他拖出来，从树上吊死了。这是一个可怕的故事，他们把他挂在那里好几天，上面挂着写有“吉姆·威廉姆斯队长”的牌子。医生在这个故事中表现得并不好。不，医生、律师，他们是可怕的人。他们在这个故事中表现得非常糟糕。现在，实际上，在这一点上，约克县一些受人尊敬的白人公民开始担心
they'd gone too far. And actually, the only newspaper, which was the Yorkville Inquirer, condemned violence on both sides. That's always the way, isn't it? Right. Good people on both sides. Yeah, correct. And said, maybe it would be good for the older men to, quote, advise the young men not to engage in whipping and murdering the coloured people. But the clan leadership was total and compromising. They issued a statement in response, the intelligent, honest white people at this county shall rule it. We can no longer put up with Negro rule, black bayonets and a miserably degraded and thievish set of lawmakers, the scum of the earth, the scrapings of creation. we are pledged to stop it, we're determined to end it, even if we are forced by force, to use force. Now, I mentioned the state governor, Robert Kingston Scott.
他们做得太过分了。事实上，唯一的报纸《约克维尔问询报》（Yorkville Inquirer）谴责了双方的暴力行为。总是这样，不是吗？没错。双方都有好人。是的，没错。并说，也许老一辈人“建议年轻人不要参与鞭打和谋杀有色人种”会更好。但三K党领导层是完全不妥协的。他们发表了一份声明作为回应：该县聪明、诚实的白人应当统治它。我们再也不能忍受黑人统治、黑人刺刀以及一群可悲的堕落和偷窃的立法者，他们是地球上的渣滓，是造物的残渣。我们誓要阻止它，我们决心结束它，即使我们被迫使用武力。现在，我提到了州长罗伯特·金斯顿·斯科特。
As was quite common, he was a former US Army officer. He came not from South Carolina, but from Ohio. So here's your classic example of what the Southerners later called carpetbaggers. You know, they had this idea that loads of unscrupulous northerners were coming down to the south with their possessions in a carpet bag to rule despotically over the ordinary people of the South. Robert Kingston Scott
正如当时很常见的那样，他是一位前美国陆军军官。他不是来自南卡罗来纳州，而是来自俄亥俄州。所以这就是南方人后来所说的“地毯包客”（carpetbaggers）的典型例子。你知道，他们有一种想法，认为大量不择手段的北方人带着他们的财产装在行李袋里来到南方，对南方普通民众进行专制统治。罗伯特·金斯顿·斯科特
doesn't really know what to do. Some of his Republican allies say to him, well, why don't you arm a black militia? Send them into your county. And his argument was, well, if I do that, that will basically mean, to use the terminology of the time, a race war.
真的不知道该怎么办。他的一些共和党盟友对他说，你为什么不武装一支黑人民兵？把他们派到你的县里去。而他的论点是，好吧，如果我那样做，那基本上意味着，用当时的话说，就是一场种族战争。
And in a race war, the white people are better armed, they're richer, they're more powerful, they will always win. Even if there are fewer of them, you know, experience shows that they will always go further, behave more badly. You know, this will invite disaster
而在种族战争中，白人装备更好，他们更富有，他们更强大，他们总是会赢。即使他们人数较少，你知道，经验表明他们总是会走得更远，表现得更恶劣。你知道，这会招致灾难
for the black people of York County. So what Scott does is he writes to Washington, begs them for more troops, and that does the trick. And in March 1871, Ulysses S. Grant decides to send three more federal companies. And Tom, I am delighted to report that they are companies of our old friends
对于约克县的黑人来说。所以斯科特所做的是写信给华盛顿，恳求他们提供更多军队，这招奏效了。1871年3月，尤利西斯·S·格兰特决定再派遣三个联邦连。汤姆，我很高兴地报告，他们是我们老朋友的连队
in the Seventh Cavalry. The Seventh Cavalry. Great to have them back on the show. Well, finally, people have been saying when are you going to do Custer Season 2? Yeah. This is it. It's the prequel.
第七骑兵团。第七骑兵团。很高兴他们回到节目中。好吧，终于，人们一直在说你们什么时候做卡斯特（Custer）第二季？是的。就是这个。这是前传。
It's the prequel to... The Phantom Menace of the Custer series. So, actually, the 7th Cavalry who were sent to York County are commanded by a much less famous person, but a more impressive person. Can you get more impressive than George Armstrong Custer? You can.
这是……卡斯特系列《幽灵的威胁》（The Phantom Menace）的前传。所以，实际上，被派往约克县的第七骑兵团是由一个不太出名但更令人印象深刻的人指挥的。你能比乔治·阿姆斯特朗·卡斯特（George Armstrong Custer）更令人印象深刻吗？你可以。
He's called Major Lewis Merrill. So I looked him up. Yeah. His beard, it has to be said, is not impressive. No. Custer has stronger hair action. I'm going to make a comparison in a moment that will please you. Major Meryl came from Pennsylvania.
他叫刘易斯·梅里尔（Lewis Merrill）少校。所以我查了一下他。是的。他的胡子，不得不说，并不令人印象深刻。不。卡斯特有更强的头发表现力。我马上要做一个让你高兴的比较。梅里尔少校来自宾夕法尼亚州。
He was a dragoons officer. He had served under Custer on the frontier before being sent to York County. Custer absolutely hated him. Why? Well, maybe he was too good as well to discover. Yeah, fair enough. A couple of other 7th Cavalry characters. So one of them was Major Reno.
他是一名龙骑兵军官。在被派往约克县之前，他曾在边境在卡斯特手下服役。卡斯特绝对讨厌他。为什么？好吧，也许他太优秀了，以至于无法被发现。是的，很有道理。还有其他几个第七骑兵团的角色。其中一个是雷诺（Reno）少校。
Remember Major Reno? Yeah, the one who squeals like a hog. Yeah, but he of all people said of Major Merrill, the Major Merrill was a notorious coward and a shirk. God, that's a bit rich. Right. And you'll remember, of course, Captain Benton. Of course.
还记得雷诺少校吗？是的，那个像猪一样尖叫的人。是的，但他竟然说梅里尔少校是个臭名昭著的懦夫和逃兵。天哪，这太离谱了。没错。当然，你还会记得本顿（Benton）上尉。当然。
Who could forget Captain Benton? The one who was very like you. Behind his chubby, cheap, cordiality was a dark and sinister intelligence. Yes, that one. Captain Benton said of, of Reno and Merrill. As poor a soldier as Reno was, he was a long way ahead of Merrill. Benton also said of Merrill that Merrill was a chump.
谁能忘记本顿上尉？那个和你很像的人。在他那圆润、廉价的亲切感背后，是一种黑暗而险恶的智慧。是的，就是那个。本顿上尉谈到雷诺和梅里尔时说：雷诺是个糟糕的士兵，但他比梅里尔强多了。本顿还说梅里尔是个笨蛋。
Wow. So anyway, he comes to poor reviews from three ludicrous men. So actually, that should alert people that actually he's probably a good guy. He is. He's the hero of this story. So the New York Tribune said of him, he has the head, face and spectacles of a German professor and the frame of an athlete.
哇。所以无论如何，他从三个荒谬的人那里得到了糟糕的评价。所以实际上，这应该提醒人们，他可能是一个好人。他是。他是这个故事的英雄。所以《纽约论坛报》（New York Tribune）评价他：他有着德国教授的头颅、面孔和眼镜，以及运动员的体格。
Does that remind you of anybody, Tom? Well, modesty prevents me from saying he sounds exactly like me. Major Lewis Merrill is literally the Tom Holland of Pennsylvania. And he's the hero of this story. He is the hero of this story. He is the hero of this story. So Major Lewis Merrill arrives in York County. He is skeptical about all this stuff about the clan.
这让你想起了谁吗，汤姆？好吧，谦虚使我无法说他听起来完全像我。刘易斯·梅里尔少校简直就是宾夕法尼亚州的汤姆·霍兰德。他是这个故事的英雄。他是这个故事的英雄。他是这个故事的英雄。所以刘易斯·梅里尔少校抵达了约克县。他对所有关于三K党的事情持怀疑态度。
He just doesn't. He thinks the stories are exaggerated. You know, he's had no experience of it and he thinks, this is probably a lot of rubbish. And he arrives and he starts talking to the victims and he is horrified by what he finds. He says, I never conceived of such a state of social disorganization being possible in any civilized community as exists in this county now. And he starts to gather evidence and then he realizes what he's up against. I mean, it is like the plot of a film or something.
他只是不相信。他认为这些故事被夸大了。你知道，他没有这方面的经验，他认为这可能是一堆垃圾。他抵达后开始与受害者交谈，他对自己所发现的一切感到震惊。他说，我从未想过在任何文明社会中会出现这种社会混乱状态，就像现在这个县存在的那样。他开始收集证据，然后他意识到自己面对的是什么。我的意思是，这就像电影的情节之类的。
He realizes every local official in the county is a Klansman. there is a grand jury, but the judge is a Klansman, most of the jurors themselves are Klansmen, and two of them have actually been involved in Klan murders. So Merylis arrived, he's been there a few weeks, and then on the night of the 5th of May, there was the most shocking, I think in many ways the most shocking of all Klan attacks. And the victim of this attack was a Baptist preacher, a black man called Elias Hill, and Elias Hill was about 50. He had been born into slavery in York County, but from the age of seven he had been severely
他意识到县里每一个地方官员都是三K党成员。有一个大陪审团，但法官是三K党成员，大多数陪审员本身就是三K党成员，其中两人实际上参与了三K党的谋杀案。所以梅里尔到了，他已经在那里待了几周，然后在5月5日晚上，发生了我认为在许多方面都是所有三K党袭击中最令人震惊的一起。这次袭击的受害者是一位浸信会传教士，一个叫埃利亚斯·希尔（Elias Hill）的黑人，埃利亚斯·希尔大约50岁。他出生在约克县的奴隶家庭，但从七岁起他就严重
disabled. It's not clear whether it was polio or muscular dystrophy or something along those lines. So he can't walk, he can't crawl, he needs help to clothe and to feed himself. He is a very impressive person. He had learned to read and write. He'd been taught by local white children that he kind of played with. After the civil war, he became an ordained preacher. He was the president of the local union league and he opened a school for black children. And all of this, of course, brought him to the attention of the clan. And the fact that he was so severely disabled did not protect him. Because at midnight on the 5th of May, a group of clansmen burst into his cabin.
残疾。不清楚是小儿麻痹症还是肌肉萎缩症之类的。所以他不能走路，不能爬行，需要帮助才能穿衣和进食。他是一个非常令人印象深刻的人。他学会了读写。他是和当地白人孩子一起玩时被教的。内战后，他成为了一名受戒的传教士。他是当地工会联盟的主席，并为黑人儿童开办了一所学校。所有这些当然引起了三K党的注意。他身体残疾的事实并没有保护他。因为在5月5日午夜，一群三K党成员闯入了他的木屋。
They dragged him out into the yard. They beat him. They lashed him with a horse whip. They said that he was stirring up a race war. They accused him absurdly of plotting a campaign of rape against white women. And they beat him all night. They didn't kill him. But the story became a gigantic scandal because, of course, the fact that he was so badly disabled
他们把他拖到院子里。他们殴打他。他们用马鞭抽打他。他们说他在煽动种族战争。他们荒谬地指控他策划针对白人妇女的强奸运动。他们整晚都在殴打他。他们没有杀他。但这个故事变成了一个巨大的丑闻，因为当然，他身体残疾得如此严重
and that he couldn't escape, fight back or anything like that, and that he was such an impressive guy. And he's a man of the cloth. And a man of the cloth and all of this kind of thing. It explains why he becomes such a big scandal. And a few months later, actually, Hill left for Liberia. And he went with about 100 other African Americans, many of them from York County. So that's in Africa.
而且他无法逃脱、反抗或做任何类似的事情，而且他是一个如此令人印象深刻的人。他还是个神职人员。一个神职人员等等。这解释了为什么他会成为如此大的丑闻。几个月后，希尔实际上离开了去利比里亚。他和其他大约100名非裔美国人一起去了，其中许多人来自约克县。所以那是在非洲。
Yeah. So Liberia and West Africa. and he told a congressional committee before he went. He said, we're going because, quote, we do not believe it is possible for our people to live in this country peaceably. And his story ended very sadly because, like a lot of people who emigrated to Liberia at the time, he got malaria pretty much straight away and he died after six months. And that was the end of him.
是的。所以利比里亚在西非。他在离开前告诉国会委员会。他说，我们离开是因为——引用他的话——我们不相信我们的人民有可能在这个国家和平生活。他的故事结局非常悲惨，因为像当时许多移民到利比里亚的人一样，他几乎立刻就得了疟疾，六个月后就去世了。这就是他的结局。
And for Major Merrill, the Tom Holland of this story, the attack on Hill is pretty much the last straw. He summoned a group of the sort of bigwigs of U.S. York County, and he said, I know some of you are Klansman. If you do not stop this now, Washington will take really drastic measures. But of course, the question is, will Washington ever take the measures that are necessary? So Ulysses S. Grant has been president since March 1869. He's been walking this very fine line, because on the one hand, he's the hero of the north, he's the champion of radical reconstruction, he has delivered the 15th Amendment, which
对于梅里尔少校，这个故事里的汤姆·霍兰德来说，对希尔的袭击几乎是压死骆驼的最后一根稻草。他召集了一群约克县的大人物，他说，我知道你们中有些人是三K党。如果你们现在不停止，华盛顿将采取非常严厉的措施。但当然，问题是，华盛顿会采取必要的措施吗？所以尤利西斯·S·格兰特自1869年3月以来一直担任总统。他一直走在一条非常微妙的线上，因为一方面，他是北方的英雄，是激进重建的捍卫者，他通过了第15修正案，该修正案
supposedly gives black men the right to vote. On the other hand, Grant's campaign slogan was, let us have peace. And that implies that this whole business is going to go away. His cabinet is full of relative moderates. Personally, he's pragmatic and he's quite cautious and conservative and so on.
理应赋予黑人投票权。另一方面，格兰特的竞选口号是“让我们拥有和平”。这意味着这一切都会过去。他的内阁里充满了相对温和派。就个人而言，他务实且相当谨慎和保守等等。
And there are actually a lot of people in his party, allies of his, who are saying, okay we really have had enough now. The 15th Amendment gives African Americans the right to vote and that should be it. So a good example is a guy who was another civil war hero called James Garfield, goes on to become president, who's a moderate Republican congressman. Garfield said, and I quote,
实际上他的党内有很多盟友说，好吧，我们现在真的受够了。第15修正案赋予了非裔美国人投票权，这就应该足够了。所以一个很好的例子是一个叫詹姆斯·加菲尔德（James Garfield）的内战英雄，后来成为总统，他是一位温和的共和党国会议员。加菲尔德说，我引用一下，
the 15th Amendment confers upon the African race the care of its own destiny. It places their fortunes in their own hands. So if they're being lynched, it's their own fault. basically. I guess the thing is these people are raised in the world of laissez-faire. You know,
第15修正案赋予了非洲种族照顾自己命运的权利。它把他们的命运掌握在他们自己手中。所以如果他们被私刑处死，那是他们自己的错。基本上。我想问题是这些人是在自由放任的世界中长大的。你知道，
laissez-faire, small-l liberalism is an enormous element of Republican Party ideology. And actually one reason they didn't like slavery, a lot of these people, is they thought,
自由放任、小政府自由主义是共和党意识形态的一个重要组成部分。实际上，这些人不喜欢奴隶制的一个原因是他们认为，
it offended laissez-faire. It didn't, you know, slavery was paternalistic and feudal. And it denied you your free lay-s and your freedom of expression and your ability to make something of yourself, to stand on your own two feet. But they really do believe that excessive government intervention would be as bad.
它冒犯了自由放任。它没有，你知道，奴隶制是家长式的和封建的。它剥夺了你的自由放任、你的表达自由以及你成就自我、独立自主的能力。但他们确实认为过度的政府干预会同样糟糕。
But essentially what they're saying is that black people in these counties where there is this great explosion of violence, what they should be doing is arming themselves and taking the fight to the clansmen. I mean, effectively that is a recipe for this race war that they keep talking about. I don't disagree with you, by the way. To be fair to Washington, there is still just enough to use an expression that our American listeners we enjoy. There are still enough gasoline left in the tank for them to do something about this. So in May 1870, February 1871, Congress passed two enforcement acts to prevent terror and intimidation in elections. And they took the jurisdiction away from the state courts to the federal courts to try to basically exercise
但本质上他们所说的是，在暴力大爆发的这些县里的黑人，他们应该做的是武装自己，并与三K党成员进行斗争。我的意思是，实际上这正是他们一直在谈论的那场种族战争的处方。顺便说一句，我并不反对你。公平地说，华盛顿仍然有足够的——用我们美国听众喜欢的表达方式——油箱里还有足够的汽油让他们对此做点什么。所以1870年5月、1871年2月，国会通过了两项执法法案，以防止选举中的恐怖和恐吓。他们将管辖权从州法院转移到联邦法院，以试图基本上行使
some kind of supervision. And then April 1871, they passed the Coo Clucks Can Act. And this made it a federal offence, not a state offence, to conspire, to deny other people's political rights. And it gave the president power to send in troops against the clan, crucially, to suspend habeas corpus and to make arrests without charge. In other words, they give the president that power. Now, the thing is, this goes back to the exchange we were just having. This was so massively controversial at the time. First of all, the Democrats hated it. The Democrats said this is destroying civil liberty.
某种监督。然后1871年4月，他们通过了《三K党法案》（Ku Klux Klan Act）。这使得密谋剥夺他人的政治权利成为联邦罪行，而不是州罪行。它赋予总统派遣军队对抗三K党的权力，关键是，暂停人身保护令并进行无指控逮捕。换句话说，他们赋予了总统那种权力。现在，问题是，这回到了我们刚才的交流。这在当时引起了巨大的争议。首先，民主党人讨厌它。民主党人说这正在摧毁公民自由。
It's destroying self-government. This is Ulysses S. Grant, arresting people without charge, sending in troops. He is making himself a dictator. Yeah. But even many Republicans, including people who've been really close to Abraham Lincoln and who have been passionate abolitionists, said, this is going much too far. This is undermining our system.
它正在摧毁自治。这是尤利西斯·S·格兰特，在没有指控的情况下逮捕人，派遣军队。他正在把自己变成独裁者。是的。但即使是许多共和党人，包括那些与亚伯拉罕·林肯非常亲近且一直是热情的废奴主义者的人，也说，这走得太远了。这正在破坏我们的制度。
This is undermining civil liberties. You know, this far and absolutely no further. However, for Major Merrill, this is the weapon he needs. So he reported to a congressional committee. Grant sent his Attorney General to South Carolina, who was a... His Attorney General, interestingly, was a lawyer called Amos T. Aikerman,
这正在破坏公民自由。你知道，到此为止，绝对不能再进一步了。然而，对于梅里尔少校来说，这是他需要的武器。所以他向国会委员会作了报告。格兰特派他的司法部长去南卡罗来纳州，他……有趣的是，他的司法部长是一位叫阿莫斯·T·艾克曼（Amos T. Aikerman）的律师，
who had seen the clan at first hand because he'd organized the Republican Party in Georgia. in the late 1860s. And Aikerman went to York County and he met Merrill and he came back to Washington and he said, this guy Merrill is absolutely brilliant. He loved Merrill. And what he said was, he said the thing that impresses me about Merrill
他亲眼目睹了三K党，因为他在19世纪60年代末组织了佐治亚州的共和党。艾克曼去了约克县，他见到了梅里尔，回到华盛顿后他说，这个梅里尔绝对是个天才。他很喜欢梅里尔。他说的是，他说梅里尔让他印象深刻的是
is that Merrill went to York County and he didn't believe in the clan and he thought it was exaggerated. And precisely because of that we should take him more seriously. The safer because incredulous at the outset and therefore disposed to scrutinize reports them more keenly is what he said of Merrill.
梅里尔去了约克县，他不相信三K党，认为它是被夸大的。正因为如此，我们才应该更认真地对待他。正如他评价梅里尔时所说，因为起初持怀疑态度，所以更倾向于敏锐地审查关于他们的报告。
Yeah, and Resolute, collected, bold and prudent, very discriminating between truth and falsehood. So just like me. Yeah, I knew you were going to quote that. You saw an opportunity to quote that and talk to basically make it about yourself and you took it and I respect it. I was waiting for you to read that out and you didn't, so I was making out for it. I mean, I would have done the same.
是的，而且坚定、冷静、大胆、审慎，非常善于区分真假。就像我一样。是的，我知道你会引用那段话。你看到了一个引用那段话的机会，基本上是为了谈论你自己，你抓住了它，我很尊重这一点。我一直在等你读出来，但你没有，所以我补上了。我的意思是，我会做同样的事。
So October 1871, Grant proclaimed a state of lawlessness in nine South Carolina counties and he flooded them with troops and he said. suspended habeas corpus. So this is the thing that would have worked, right? But to get him to do it in just nine counties of South Carolina, so not even the whole state, is a huge undertaking. So the idea of him doing it across the whole of the South is just, I think, utterly implausible. Anyway, he did it. The troops started making mass arrests. In York County alone, they locked up 200 people. By the end of the year, about 500 more people had voluntarily surrendered and given evidence and the clan leaders all fled. A lot of them fled to Canada. And it worked. By the end of
所以1871年10月，格兰特宣布南卡罗来纳州的九个县处于无法无天状态，他用军队淹没了它们，并说暂停了人身保护令。所以这就是会奏效的事情，对吧？但要让他只在南卡罗来纳州的九个县这样做，甚至不是整个州，都是一项巨大的任务。所以他要在整个南方这样做，我认为是完全不可信的。无论如何，他做了。军队开始进行大规模逮捕。仅在约克县，他们就关押了200人。到年底，大约又有500人自愿投降并提供了证据，三K党领袖全部逃跑了。他们中的许多人逃到了加拿大。这奏效了。到
1871, the clan in York County had basically ceased to exist and violence fell and the elections of 1872 were much more peaceful than previous years. In other words, finally Grant basically grasped the nettle. He sent in the troops. He made all these mass arrests without charge and it ended up working. And what happens to the clan leaders once they've been locked up? Are they kept in prison for a long time or are they let out or what happens? It's not really a happy ending because the answer is nothing. Most people who are arrested are never prosecuted. And even those prosecutions that happen don't really go anywhere.
1871年底，约克县的三K党基本上已经不复存在，暴力事件减少，1872年的选举比往年和平得多。换句话说，格兰特终于基本上抓住了重点。他派出了军队。他进行了所有这些无指控的大规模逮捕，最终奏效了。那么三K党领袖被关押后会发生什么？他们被长期关在监狱里，还是被释放了，或者发生了什么？这并不是一个圆满的结局，因为答案是什么都没有发生。大多数被捕的人从未被起诉。即使是那些发生的起诉也没有真正取得任何进展。
Most of the charges ended up being dropped or a lot of the defendants are actually pardoned. And actually, northerners who went to report on this were often really shocked and sort of depressed by what they found. The New York Tribune sent a reporter. And he said, when he talked to white people in York County, and I quote, there seemed to be almost no public sense of right and wrong, no appreciation of the heinousness of crimes committed upon helpless and unoffending people. And the attorney general, to this guy, Amos T. Aikerman, you know, who had pulled this off, basically, he had got his way. He said afterwards, I feel greatly saddened by this business. It has revealed a perversion of moral sentiment among the southern whites, which bodes ill for that part of the
大多数指控最终都被撤销了，或者许多被告实际上被赦免了。事实上，去报道这件事的北方人经常对他们所发现的情况感到非常震惊和沮丧。《纽约论坛报》派了一名记者。他说，当他与约克县的白人交谈时——我引用一下——似乎几乎没有公众的是非感，没有意识到对无助和无辜的人犯下的罪行是多么令人发指。而司法部长，对这个人，阿莫斯·T·艾克曼，你知道，他基本上完成了这件事，他得偿所愿了。他事后说，我对这件事感到非常悲伤。它揭示了南方白人道德情感的扭曲，这对该地区这一代人来说是个坏兆头。
country for this generation. And I think he was right, and I think this is the big sort of, as it were, the takeaway from all this. Because the clan was beaten. The clan basically by this point late 1871, 1872, has completely ceased to exist. But it has already achieved most of what it wanted to do. So in some states, the clan made a massive difference. It made an electoral difference. So the Democrats have already regained control, for example, of Georgia and Alabama in 1870. The clan smashed the Republican Party in the South. It destroyed local organizations. It made it impossible to basically be an open Republican.
我认为他是对的，我认为这就是这一切的重大收获。因为三K党被击败了。到1871年底、1872年，三K党基本上已经完全不复存在。但它已经实现了它想要做的大部分事情。所以在一些州，三K党产生了巨大的影响。它产生了选举影响。例如，民主党在1870年已经重新控制了佐治亚州和阿拉巴马州。三K党粉碎了南方的共和党。它摧毁了当地组织。它使得基本上不可能成为一名公开的共和党人。
One Mississippi Republican said, you can't basically have your best and most reliable workers murdered with impunity and hope to function as a democratic organization. And so the South will remain Democrat for decades and decades to come. Exactly. It destroys the institutions of the black freed men and freed women. So their churches, their schools and so on. Don't forget these institutions are so precious because they're so new and because their independence is so fragile. And of course, the other big thing, it does what the Southerners had always planned to do. It destroys the patience and the political will of people in the north. So if you get to like, I don't know, 1872, you are 12 years on from the election of Abraham Lincoln and the outbreak. of the war pretty much. And if you're in the north, you're sitting there in, you know, Illinois or Maine or wherever it might be.
一位密西西比州的共和党人说，你基本上不能让最优秀、最可靠的工人在不受惩罚的情况下被谋杀，还指望能作为一个民主组织运作。因此，南方在未来几十年里将保持民主党阵营。没错。这摧毁了黑人自由民的制度，比如他们的教堂、学校等等。别忘了，这些制度之所以珍贵，是因为它们太新了，而且它们的独立性非常脆弱。当然，另一件大事是，它实现了南方人一直计划做的事情。它摧毁了北方人民的耐心和政治意愿。所以如果你到了，我不知道，1872年，距离亚伯拉罕·林肯当选和战争爆发已经过去了12年。如果你在北方，你坐在伊利诺伊州或缅因州或其他任何地方。
You've got a fat cigar. You've got a top hat. You're making loads of money in railroads. Yeah. Right. And you're thinking to yourself, 12 years now, I've been listening to all this stuff and I'm apps. It's the most boring subjects in the world. It's a little bit when people used to say, we used the Northern Ireland parallel earlier.
你抽着粗雪茄，戴着高礼帽，在铁路生意上赚了大钱。是的，没错。你心里想，12年了，我一直在听这些东西，这简直是世界上最无聊的话题。这有点像人们过去常说的，我们之前用了北爱尔兰的类比。
People in Britain never had strong views about Northern Ireland. They actually, as you will remember, Tom, to the disbelief of people in Northern Ireland, people in Britain would often say they found it really boring and they wished it would go away. And I think that's exactly how most people in the north think about the South. They just find the subject, they're sick of it. They don't understand it, they're bored of it. They want everyone to stop talking about it. And they actually think at this point, if the Southern Republicans and the Black people in the South can't defend themselves, Sodom. you know, just fine.
英国人对北爱尔兰从来没有强烈的看法。正如你所记得的，汤姆，令北爱尔兰人难以置信的是，英国人经常说他们觉得这真的很无聊，希望它消失。我认为这正是大多数北方人对南方的看法。他们只是觉得这个话题很烦人，他们厌倦了它。他们不理解它，他们对它感到厌烦。他们希望每个人都停止谈论它。而且他们实际上认为在这一点上，如果南方共和党人和南方的黑人不能保护自己，那就随他们去吧。
The South is the South is never going to change. I'm not going to spend loads of tax dollars on federal troops. You know, you can't have half of your country under military occupation the whole time. Just let them get on with it. And so because of all this, I don't think there is an alternative reality in which this could have worked out differently. First of all, I think there was never the will in the North to sustain a massive long-term military occupation. They were never going to pay for it. They're never going to rip up the federal system.
南方永远不会改变。我不会花大量的税款在联邦军队上。你知道，你不能一直让半个国家处于军事占领之下。让他们自己处理吧。所以因为这一切，我不认为存在一个可以有不同结果的替代现实。首先，我认为北方从来没有维持大规模长期军事占领的意愿。他们永远不会为此买单。他们永远不会撕毁联邦制度。
That's one thing. But then the other thing, two-thirds of the people in the Confederacy are white. And they were just not prepared to accept the equality of their former slaves. They would never have accepted it. These include the richest, most powerful, most influential people in that part of the world. And white supremacy was of such existential importance to them that they would, do anything to preserve it. I mean, they fought a civil war to preserve it. The fact that they lost, they haven't changed their minds. They still think there is an, you know, an indissoluble
这是一回事。但另一件事是，邦联三分之二的人口是白人。他们根本没有准备好接受他们前奴隶的平等地位。他们永远不会接受。这些人包括那个地区最富有、最强大、最有影响力的人。白人至上主义对他们来说具有如此的存在意义，以至于他们会不惜一切代价来维护它。我的意思是，他们打了一场内战来维护它。他们失败的事实并没有改变他们的想法。他们仍然认为存在着一种，你知道，不可分割的
war between the races and they will do anything to restore it. And they do. Because I suppose essentially what it would require would be an equivalent of denazification in Germany after the Second World War. Yeah. And I suppose the federal government just lacks the resources and perhaps even the will to force that through? Completely. So just to finish off this part of the story, by the 1870s, most people in the north have lost interest, including many Republicans.
种族间的战争，他们会不惜一切代价恢复它。他们确实这样做了。因为我想本质上这需要像二战后德国的去纳粹化一样。是的。我想联邦政府只是缺乏资源，甚至可能缺乏强制执行的意愿？完全正确。所以为了结束故事的这一部分，到了1870年代，大多数北方人已经失去了兴趣，包括许多共和党人。
There was then a massive financial crash in 1873, which triggered a depression that lasted for most of the rest of the decade. That was terrible news to the Republicans, of course, because they were the party in power. So the Democrats then made huge gains. They regained control of the House of Representatives. At the same time, there's a general retreat from federal intervention,
随后在1873年发生了大规模的金融崩溃，引发了一场持续了该十年大部分时间的萧条。这对共和党人来说当然是可怕的消息，因为他们是执政党。因此，民主党人获得了巨大的收益。他们重新获得了众议院的控制权。与此同时，联邦干预出现了普遍的退缩，
the Supreme Court starts to gut a lot of the reconstruction legislation. It reinterprets the 14th Amendment. It makes it much harder for the federal government to enforce the laws that had been passed in the 1860s. And so what you have in the 1870s is one state after another falling back to the Democrats, often in very violent circumstances. So the end of the clan does not mean the end of the terrorist violence. There are successor groups, which nobody talks about now, a group in Louisiana, called the White League, or a group in Mississippi and the Carolinas called the red shirts,
最高法院开始废除许多重建立法。它重新解释了第14修正案。这使得联邦政府更难执行1860年代通过的法律。因此，在1870年代，一个又一个州倒向了民主党，通常是在非常暴力的环境下。所以三K党的终结并不意味着恐怖暴力的终结。有一些继任组织，现在没人谈论了，路易斯安那州的一个组织叫白人联盟，或者密西西比州和卡罗来纳州的一个组织叫红衫军，
that there's loads of violence at election times. And then once the Democrats have got control back, they don't need the violence anymore because they can pass laws to stop black people voting, like literacy tests or poll taxes. And so they win. Are these groups not remembered because they lack the branding of the clan? They lack the pointy hats and all that. They don't have the same branding and they don't have successes. The clan would probably be forgotten where we're not for the second clan, which will come to you next time. The clan would be like the knights of the white camellia. They'd be a sort of slightly lurid, exotic paramilitary group of the 1860s and 70s.
选举时有大量的暴力事件。一旦民主党重新获得控制权，他们就不再需要暴力了，因为他们可以通过法律来阻止黑人投票，比如识字测试或人头税。所以他们赢了。这些组织不被记住是因为它们缺乏三K党的品牌效应吗？它们缺乏尖顶帽之类的东西。它们没有同样的品牌，也没有取得同样的成功。如果不是因为第二次三K党，三K党可能早就被遗忘了，我们下次会讲到。三K党就像白茶花骑士团。它们是1860年代和70年代一种稍微耸人听闻、充满异国情调的准军事组织。
But yeah, when people ever talked about the red shirts, you know, they're not forgotten, but they're very effective. Actually, here's a thing that really surprised me. The worst violence of war, and actually it happens after the clan has disappeared. So the single worst incident was in Colfax, Louisiana, in April and 1873. there'd been a contested election for the state governor. So there are sort of rival governors. There's a group of black Republicans are cornered in the Colfax Courthouse by white paramilitaries.
但是，当人们谈论红衫军时，你知道，他们并没有被遗忘，但他们非常有效。其实，有一件事让我非常惊讶。战争中最严重的暴力，实际上发生在三K党消失之后。所以最严重的单一事件发生在1873年4月的路易斯安那州科尔法克斯。当时州长选举存在争议。所以有竞争的州长。一群黑人共和党人被白人准军事组织困在了科尔法克斯法院。
And the white paramilitaries killed about 150 people. God. Yeah. That's a lot of people. I mean, it's a lot of people. When you think how much something like the so-called Peterloo massacre, right, is commemorated in Britain, it's a really good reminder of how much more violent American democracy has always been than British democracy, for example.
白人准军事组织杀害了大约150人。天哪。是的。那是很多人。我的意思是，那是很多人。当你想到像所谓的彼得卢大屠杀这样的事情在英国被纪念的程度时，这确实是一个很好的提醒，提醒人们美国民主一直比英国民主暴力得多。
I mean, there is a sort of culture of armed violence that is just unthinkable in our own dear country, Tom. Good. Well, I'm glad that we emerge from this story well. So the last name in the coffin, so-called compromise of 1877, presidential election of 1876 ends in deadlock between Republic. Rutherford B. Hayes and the Democrat Samuel J. Tilden, basically do a deal. The Republicans can keep the presidency, and in return, Rutherford B. Hayes will withdraw the last federal troops
我的意思是，有一种武装暴力的文化，在我们亲爱的国家是不可想象的，汤姆。很好。好吧，我很高兴我们从这个故事中走出来了。所以棺材里的最后一个钉子，所谓的1877年妥协，1876年总统选举以共和党人拉瑟福德·B·海斯和民主党人塞缪尔·J·蒂尔登之间的僵局告终，基本上达成了一项协议。共和党人可以保留总统职位，作为交换，拉瑟福德·B·海斯将撤出最后一批联邦军队
from South Carolina, Louisiana, and Florida, and now the Democrats have kind of carte blanche to regain control. Reconstruction is over. The laws are rolled back. Racial segregation ends up being enshrined in law a generation later. The Jim Crow system, Tom, that you were talking about. And actually, well, elements of this is lynching becomes almost institutionalized. So by the 1890s, you have hundreds of black men being lynched every year.
从南卡罗来纳州、路易斯安那州和佛罗里达州撤出，现在民主党人有了某种全权来重新获得控制权。重建结束了。法律被废除。种族隔离最终在这一代人之后被写入法律。汤姆，你提到的吉姆·克劳制度。实际上，好吧，其中的一些元素是私刑几乎制度化了。所以到了1890年代，每年都有数百名黑人被私刑处死。
And the Ku Klux Klan itself is now no more than a memory. So a generation after the this has all happened, so you get to the 1890s and the 1900s, it's sort of bundled in to this new cult of the lost cause of the Confederacy. So these are people who are, you know, there are still Confederate heroes who are alive, you know, they're white bearded now. But their successors, the generation below them, who have, you know, reintegrated into the Union, to the United States. But they share this idea that although the South lost, it stood for something noble and precious, a kind of hierarchical, feudal way of life. you know, this is the ideal that is celebrated in Gone with the Wind. Yeah, that famous kind of opening, the introduction.
而三K党本身现在已不再是记忆。所以这一切发生了一代人之后，当你到了1890年代和1900年代，它被捆绑进了这种新的邦联“迷途事业”崇拜中。所以这些人是，你知道，仍然有活着的邦联英雄，你知道，他们现在是白胡子老头了。但他们的继任者，他们下一代的人，已经重新融入了联邦，融入了美国。但他们分享着这样一种观点，即尽管南方输了，但它代表了一些高尚和珍贵的东西，一种等级森严的封建生活方式。你知道，这就是《乱世佳人》中赞美的理想。是的，那种著名的开场，介绍。
Yeah, that the sort of noble gentleman. Men were knights and ladies were princesses and all of that. Yeah. And the black people knew, you know, they had their place. They were happy. They knew their place, yes. Yeah. I mean, this is the lost cause idea.
是的，那种高尚的绅士。男人是骑士，女士是公主，诸如此类。是的。而且黑人知道，你知道，他们有自己的位置。他们很幸福。他们知道自己的位置，是的。是的。我的意思是，这就是“迷途事业”的理念。
And in this version of history, the clan are not racist vigilantes, but they are the intrepid, swashbuckling defenders of white civilisation. So the first historical account of the clan, published in 1905, by a professor of history of Vanderbilt, quite a distinguished historian by the standards of the time, called Walter Linwood Fleming. Walter Linwood Fleming's father had been a planter and a slave owner and a Confederate cavalry man. And Walter Linwood Fleming said of the clan, the Ku Klux movement was the effort by the southern white people to restore order and maintain control of their civilization, caused by the
在这个版本的历史中，三K党不是种族主义的治安维持者，而是白人文明勇敢、挥舞刀剑的捍卫者。所以关于三K党的第一份历史记录，由范德比尔特大学的历史学教授于1905年出版，按当时的标准来看是一位相当杰出的历史学家，名叫沃尔特·林伍德·弗莱明。沃尔特·林伍德·弗莱明的父亲曾是一名种植园主、奴隶主和邦联骑兵。沃尔特·林伍德·弗莱明这样评价三K党：三K党运动是南方白人为了恢复秩序并保持对其文明的控制而做出的努力，这是由
disorder in the South, the inefficiency and corruption of the governments, and the alarm of the whites and Negro domination. He says it wasn't a criminal group. It was composed of men of standing in their communities, and its declared object was to protect society from lawlessness. And he goes on to say there were excesses, but the organisation as a whole aimed at restraint and control rather than destruction. And this, as shocking as it might now seem, becomes the standard view, both in academia and in popular culture. And in popular culture, the key figure who enshrines this is a writer and failed politician
南方的混乱、政府的无能和腐败，以及白人对黑人统治的恐慌所引起的。他说它不是一个犯罪组织。它由社区中有地位的人组成，其宣称的目标是保护社会免受无法无天的侵害。他接着说，虽然有过激行为，但整个组织旨在克制和控制，而不是破坏。而这，尽管现在看起来可能令人震惊，却成为了学术界和流行文化中的标准观点。在流行文化中，确立这一点的关键人物是一位来自北卡罗来纳州的作家、失败的政治家
and failed Baptist minister from North Carolina called Thomas Dixon. And Thomas Dixon's father had been a member of the clan, his uncle had been in the clan, one of its leaders, in fact. And Dixon in 1915 turned their lives into the inspiration for a novel called The Clansman, which then became a very popular play. And then in 1915, the most innovative film director of the age, one of the most innovative directors has ever lived, D.W. Griffith turns it into the first great narrative feature film, the birth of a nation.
和失败的浸信会牧师，名叫托马斯·狄克逊。托马斯·狄克逊的父亲曾是三K党成员，他的叔叔也是三K党成员，事实上还是领导人之一。狄克逊在1915年将他们的生活变成了小说《族人》的灵感来源，该小说后来成为一部非常受欢迎的戏剧。然后在1915年，那个时代最具创新精神的电影导演，有史以来最具创新精神的导演之一，D.W.格里菲斯将其改编成了第一部伟大的叙事长片，《一个国家的诞生》。
And this is a film that does two things. It revolutionizes cinema, but it also resurrects the Ku Klux Klan, because just months after the release of birth of a nation, a second clan is born, and by the mid-1920s, that second clan has literally millions of members. And so, Dominic, that is the story, the birth of nation,
这是一部做了两件事的电影。它彻底改变了电影业，但也复活了三K党，因为在《一个国家的诞生》上映仅几个月后，第二个三K党就诞生了，到1920年代中期，第二个三K党拥有了数百万成员。所以，多米尼克，这就是故事，《一个国家的诞生》，
the rebirth of the clan that we will be telling next time. And it has, I think, all kinds of unexpected nuances and dimensions that was kind of news to me. And club members, of course, can hear that episode and the final episode in this series. right away. If you are not a club member and you would like to hear those two, then you can go to the rest is history.com. If you don't want to do any of that, then both episodes will be out next week. Thank you, Dominic. Thank you everyone for listening. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们下次将讲述三K党的重生。我认为它有各种意想不到的细微差别和维度，这对我来说有点新鲜。当然，俱乐部成员可以立即收听那一集和本系列的最后一集。如果你不是俱乐部成员，想听这两集，那么你可以去therestishistory.com。如果你不想做这些，那么两集都将在下周发布。谢谢你，多米尼克。谢谢大家的收听。再见。再见。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。